[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our lives
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now anyone can learn and improve their
chest skills with the world champion
Magnus Carlsen
the Magnus trainer app is packed with
fun minigames in interactive training
content playable anytime anywhere get
the Magnus trainer available in the App
Store and Google Play
[Music]
if you're a chess player you have plenty
of opportunities to challenge and play
online against the top players
participating in the chess about masters
super tournament don't miss the
opportunity to learn from the best check
out the chess 24 shows area and tune in
for banter blitzes with the likes of
Magnus Carlsen Fabiano Cara Juana
Alexander Chris Chuck and bent Allah
Hari Krishna go premium at chess 24 to
challenge them and gain full access to
the world's most entertaining chess
platform
[Music]
[Music]
whoa I think he's getting a mated now
chief rg3 right how did how did we get
here so after Bishop a1 ding played
rukka fade picking up that tempo or with
c3 Rock f1 Bishop b2 Bishop d1 and here
he Carl play the natural natural enough
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dare I say congratulations on the seven
drawers well I'm not accepting your
correlations I want I want correlations
on much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
closed wine and welcome to my very first
course for disabled
[Music]
it's time to take control of your
journey towards chess mastery magnus
carlsen introduces chasuble the
definitive solution for studying chess
move trainer uses the science of spaced
repetition to identify your strengths
and eliminates your weaknesses there's
no need to set up a wall to remember
which page you're on or keep track of
all the moves you miss move trainer
empowers you to go from the opening to
the endgame with confidence it's a
seamless effective and fun way to study
chess choose from one of the largest
online chess libraries in the world with
hundreds of titles ranging from classic
books due to our exclusive
chasuble courses including over 100 free
courses get expert insights from
International Master John Bartholomew
Grandmaster Sam Franklin's International
Master crystal silicon Grandmaster Simon
Williams world's champion Magnus Carlsen
and hundreds of other instructors get
started now and join our growing
community of over 100,000 chess
enthusiasts at jezebel.com chasuble take
control of your journey towards chess
mastery ok hello everyone
a big welcome to each and every one of
you we are ready for day three of the
chess about masters quarterfinals I am
your host yes or Sarah Wan and our host
of social media is on a Rudolf and grand
master extraordinaire Peter Svidler
we'll be bringing you all the action
breaking it down move by move first of
all big welcome to you both and Anna
what's trending everybody thank you once
again yes as usual for the kind of
welcoming words I will be monitoring the
three chats on twitch youtube as well as
on chess 24 huge welcome to all of you
tuning in to another quarter finals day
what is trending I'm soon revealing but
before that let me also say hi to the
one and only Grandmaster Peter Svidler
Peter how are you feeling today high and
high
hi yes sir exciting day feeling all
right even though yeah it's becoming a
bit of a moot point but but no I mean
with this weather I would like to for
there to be a sea next to me not not
just my four walls of the flat I can
understand that although it's raining
today in Ireland so I may be envying the
weather in Russia right now since yes
they asked me about what's trending on
social let me bring up some of the
tweets that were the most popular topic
on social media with the hashtag study
chess of course one of them includes the
match between zingaran
and Hikaru Nakamura and even Howard
Staunton one of the strongest players of
the 19th century tweeted about the play
of the dangler and saying the Chinese
champion of the checkered field deserves
the highest compliments for the
excellent manner in which he has
conducted this match
praising ding Lorenz win over Hikaru
Nakamura the American star will need to
bounce back tomorrow if he wants to make
it to a tiebreaker on the third day of
the quarterfinals but other than the
match between ding and Hikaru the hot
topic of course was the 7 draws between
Gary and Grisha truck starting with the
moment where Magnus tweeted about the
second game where a niche had a winning
position in an end game against Grisha
Kapaun up minor piece and game and he
sported Magnus tweeted my boy NH Gary
snarking a draw from the jaws of victory
to which image responded right after the
rapid games L magneto repeating this old
joke for all the new followers he
gathered after his last match with GM
Hikaru anyway enjoy the Bliss guys so
that was a nice tweeting still in the
competition right before the Bliss game
started and Magnus responded to an ish
no joke just a public announcement
good luck now after the first four
drawers in Rapids two more drawers
fellows in the Blitz which made the
world champion tweet again about which
color will Magnus which color will Andes
choose and Magnus is Paul was the
following did Gary choose black in
Armageddon yes or what else now after it
was a joy in Armageddon T the second of
Magnus calls and Peter Haney took it to
Twitter saying there's a story in donors
excellent book the king a player
accidentally fell entering the stage and
while it could have happened to anybody
all participants would have guessed it
would happen to Deemer winning a match
by seven drools could happen to anybody
but dot dot dot so there has been a lot
of trolling about the seven drawers
unfortunately for any a lot of old memes
have been also circling on Twitter but
he himself responded by saying on
Twitter the following if we can bring up
anything sweet as the next clip one
without winning but still didn't win
referring to our typo on Instagram which
said that Grif Shaquanda match and then
he followed with looking forward to
another epic battle the day after
tomorrow in the meantime do follow me on
instagram for more insights on the
ongoing battle between me and al magneto
scorp chess 24 we will soon bring up any
she's instagram series since he's
recommending it to the viewers and on
that note yes sir what is your thoughts
what what is your opinion on yesterday's
yuri chris scherk match and do you think
there's a curse of drawers in the case
of Anish well thank you for that on it
seems like there was some very very good
poking going on there let's call it
friendly banter between the players of
course on each because of this
candidates tournament where he did draw
all all of his games has got this
reputation for drawing that I gotta tell
you something I don't think it's a
problem to be good to begin with and
I'll say put anybody in this field
players of the chest will masters and if
you can draw your games you're a great
player because these are some elite
players drawing is an art and it's hard
and you have black against Magnus
Carlsen and you'll be very very
satisfied I assure you if you make a
trough but let's set the table for today
today of course we are in day three of
the quarterfinals of this $150,000
chasuble masters tournament it's the
third leg of four qualifying events that
will get each winner to the grand and
finals of the Magnus Carlsen Tour the
Magnus Carlsen floor is a 1 million
dollar affair the grand finals
will have three hundred thousand dollars
in the prizes to the players in these
quarterfinals who do leave our event
we'll be leaving with eight thousand
dollars in the bucket and they will try
to get into the semi-finals where they
could earn a lot more money all the
games will be played at a time control
of 15 minutes for each player that's
what they begin with but for each and
every move that they make they all get a
ten-second bonus if after four games the
match remains tied at 2 to 2 then the
fires will play a pair of lits games a 5
minutes plus 3 seconds per game if the
match is still tied then they will play
one Armageddon so we can consider all
the games played today as a set of games
the players need to win two out of three
days today we are in matches AMD they
will rejoin after day 1 Magnus and neppo
lead their matches in other words if
Magnus and nepo win today they are the
semi-finalists and to call the matches
as he sees them I'm going to turn it
over to Peter and ask Peter the salient
question how did the players who are
trailing in their matches get back into
them Peter
well luckily for for for those who have
lost day one this format means that
today they start from a blank slate they
don't really day one is now firmly in
the past it no longer has any relevance
to to what's happening today and you
just need to play better than your
opponent on the day the scores are zero
zero and there's everything to play for
obviously beating magnets on demand is
is not an easy task for instance in in
case of Fabi and vladislav RT me if I
think also would have felt quite hard
done by by the events of of day one
where he lost game one by disconnecting
in severe time trouble and it wasn't
specifically the disconnect but the fact
that he could not reconnect in time
while his clock was still ticking that
ended up costing him the game such
things are quite clearly quite quite
unpleasant to face and I'm I'm sure he
would not have enjoyed in any part of it
but I think our team if is an extremely
confident young man and he will feel
that you know barring unfortunate
accidents he is not really a dog against
anybody in the world but I don't think
if there is a specific piece of advice I
would give somebody who lost the first
set just play well hope hope your
preparation pays off and for myself I
always repeat as a kind of a mantra very
important to have a fresh head just you
know don't overload yourself with with
variations don't try to guess what will
happen in terms of openings just
approach it with with as as freshly as
you can and Trust in your obviously huge
innate ability and and your intuition
and your understanding of chess in
general I think that that is fantastic
advice
and I can't express it enough that for
everybody who goes and plays in the
chess tournament a fresh head if you're
coming to the board and you're cleared
with all kinds of thoughts and you're
worried about your car or how you parked
in it or you did something wrong I mean
really take the time to take a deep
breath and settle down
fresh net it's just so so vital and
being practical
but Anna as when we brought it to you
you didn't ask answer at least the most
salient question that I would have for
you I don't know what's that question of
the day that's a very important question
indeed yes sir since every day we have a
different unique question to our dear
viewers and if you are the tweeter the
chosen tweet you will receive today's
course we will soon reveal who will be
the author of today and which course you
can win but for now let's bring on
today's question which is the following
is using an engine AI to study chess
good for your chess and please also
explain why you think yes or no and if
you use engine how would you recommend
using it so elaborate on this topic is
using an engine or AI good for studying
chess
use the hashtag study chest on Twitter
if you would like to interact with us
and answer today's question yesterday's
winner let me also show yesterday's
winning tweet was madam Genesis art he
has been blessing us with fan art and he
all standard yesterday's question by
choosing ding leerin as his been turd
bits banter blitz opponent now we will I
think in this very moment revealed the
author of the day I thought maybe we'll
wait a little bit but no let me announce
today's author who will be joining us
shortly well in an hour or so is Grand
Master Herman le'me longtime second of a
nice giri and he will be here to talk
about his opening lap the dubov Tarrasch
which today is on sale so the course
that you can win today is earrings the
dubov Tarrasch and he answered to a very
question about using engine when
studying chess and we can bring up his
answer in an interview he has given what
is the most overrated advice and he said
what do you think is the most overrated
piece of advice you hear and why don't
use a computer he thinks is the most
overrated piece and he also added you
simply have a sparing partner rated 3700
at your fingertips so there you have it
that urban's
answer also to our question of the day
but we are curious about your thoughts
on this topic do you use engine when
studying chest how do you use it what do
you think is the best way to handle it
or if you think that it's not a good
idea do let us know why by using the
hashtag study chest now back to yes sir
and what's at stake today absolutely and
it sounds to me like a win should win
the prize and win his own course just a
quick reminder of what we're trying to
do in visa broadcasts is to make them
more fun more educational a little bit
more interactive and that way that is
why anna is monitoring all the social
media channels so that you can compact
Channel questions to our panel to our
special guests that we do have on the
show we make an attempt after the games
are over to invite the players to share
their thoughts and usually we invite the
winners of the day so get your questions
ready for Anna and she will find the
questions that she likes best again
we're doing our best maker at the these
broadcasts as fun as possible also
before I turn it over to Peter with a
very big question that I have for him I
just wanted to say a big shout out to so
Terrence and Lois these are gentlemen
who are working behind the scenes to
make this broadcast possible and when
everything goes swimmingly it's
wonderful that yesterday we had some
real challenges and they were super pros
so a little love and the chat to those
two fine gentlemen who made the
broadcast possible the question I had
for you Peter is to drill down a little
bit in the matches today and talk a
little bit about the openings that we
can expect from these four great chess
players well it's easy I think to talk
about the the Khurana Carlsen match in
that respect because clearly they have
played a great deal of chess against
each other and on day one it was only it
was only the three games the first one
was a Queens gambit with a with a bit of
a sideline which gained some traction
recently and I don't know if there will
be necessarily repeated again and then
there was an Italian with far beyond the
white side and as for the opening in
Game three I think that's probably
unlikely to happen again because by that
point Fabia was trading 2-0 and had to
take perhaps more risks and he normally
would be comfortable with but they do
have as everybody understands they have
a tremendous history of playing against
each other and you can see you can see
some training topics it does appear as
if Magnus is quite interested in the
idea of playing the Sicilian against
Fabi I think ever since their match for
the World Championship of 2018 Magnus
has been doing that more and more and on
the white side Magnus does seem to play
1t for more than anything else
against Fabi with some English mixed in
well we haven't seen that two days ago
but the match just generally
so comfortably for Magnus that perhaps
he didn't feel he needed to deviate what
from what he feels is the the the
optimal opening approach as for the the
old Russian Derby
I think artemyev is a very difficult
player to predict in terms of openings
he has a quite a varied repertoire and
he also can sprinkle in pretty much
anything in particularly if he feels the
the March situation demands it such as
the e4 c5 Knight f3 a6 that he sprung on
onion in game 3 and actually got a very
playable position out of the opening
there before committing a very
uncharacteristic blunder and losing that
game as well
all in all a slightly easier to predict
the general tone of the opening let's
put it like this in the in the Carlsen
khurana yeah match and I really wouldn't
want to you know bet any money on even
the first moves in the game in the games
between the well thank you for that
Peter
it's always fun no matter what sport
you're in when number one versus a
number two go at it so that marquee
match it will certainly keep our eyes on
the back over to you Anna and the
question is what's trending I can't wait
to see the real number one versus real
number two of course but I did promise
to show you some of the Instagram posts
that you can find on Anna's Geary's
social media since he was recommending
everyone to follow him on IG so here's
some IG filled by a nice giri you can
also always get no bells what he's
having for breakfast for lunch constant
food diagram updates and polls the next
slide is a poll related to our broadcast
and I'm gonna ask yourself you to later
on to ask to answer the question if we
can show the next slide from Anna's
gears Instagram this was a tweet by Eric
asking what happened here in your first
game if you guys see there
reaction of Aneesh and Sasha at the same
time and Aneesh made a poll where the
guesses are the following a suddenly
heard yells and Co commentating b l
magneto the frog appeared on the chest
24 screen ce smith ler started drawing
arrows on our board or d we saw the 46
percent discount IDI and found it at
outrageous so if you are not following
energy on instagram you are missing out
on content like this high quality
content we will address the for later on
but now moving on to what's the pairings
for today will emerge has a fan art
showing the two pairs who will be
competing today in the quarterfinals
it is indeed Kirsten versus Karina and
Napoleon she versus artemiev both Karina
and Artemyev in a must-win situation in
terms of today's set and the final one
is a bit of behind-the-scenes
information from yummy palmistry who
played Ben Turbots yesterday on chess 24
and revealed that in his game against
Maxine Vassar a graph had trouble not
only on the chess board but also outside
the board saying that he was too busy
fighting for his life against some
mosquitoes that appeared in the room so
behind the scenes the information hoping
that there will be no mosquitoes
involved in today's match against
artemyev but now back to yes sir and
Peter yes sir what did you think of uh
nishes poll and what do you think is the
correct answer any more time I would
like for you to repeat the question
please as they say on online quiz shows
but I am always I'm always I think
fiddle or drawing arrows is the answer
to everything like whatever the question
is this has to be the correct answer
we're very proud of you Peter for your
arrows
I am I appreciate the the vote of
confidence
the arrows inspire is all I just also
like to make a quick shout out as we
getting ready for the start of the
quarter finals to chess 24-hour
co-hosting this event
there are many streams in many languages
and it's for me it's just fantastic this
technology so if you're if you want to
study chess in Russian or French or
German or even Chinese a Mandarin please
check out the other broadcasters and
presenters on chess 24 and of course
today once again we're going to have
Grand Master Erwin Lani I've known her
when she was really young he used to
come over and we do a little trainings
together a wonderful young gentleman he
is a chestful author and his course is
having an incredibly huge discount so
we'll look forward to welcoming her win
in getting him in the mix and throwing
the Patti's as we say as as the moves I
think are kind of getting ready to get
underway just a few minutes away I
believe from the start of this day two
of the matches a and B and again you
need to win two out of three days we'll
see if a B and vladislav can tie the
matches up Peter any final thoughts as
we're getting ready to go I really would
like to see at least the first moves in
those games before I commit to two
anymore punditry honestly it's a little
bit too difficult to to predict in depth
things about the openings in in rapid
and blitz events because people do take
a lot more liberties in general they
they do feel like it's less important to
be entirely correct in your approach so
to speak you you can you can definitely
take some more risks with with this
shorter time controls well it's funny
because think when I think about players
taking liberties it seems to me that
Magnus has been the one who's
especially in the openings doing funky
things the Ala camp kind is not a funky
thing per se but I'm just using that as
an example that he's he's one to welcome
going off the beaten path so to speak
very early with this lead do you think
he'll be doing anything extra funky not
at the beginning I think I think game
one week I would expect him to play what
amounts to his normal repertoire and I'm
pretty sure he would like to to to put
the match entirely to bed today he
doesn't want to day three for all kinds
of reasons it's obviously very nice to
have a an additional residue to just
recuperate play some more of that
wonderful basketball that he's so famous
for but and and of course the the
memories of the Linder asabi semi-final
even though it was the idea against a
different opponent I probably still
quite fresh and after and a very
commanding performance in the first set
he ended up not not getting to the
finals after a spirit had come back by
Hikaru Nakamura but in terms of an
opening approach and in sort of general
approach I think he respects Fabi a
little bit too much to to do anything
silly in the opening at least in the
early going alright and just to remind
everyone what Peters talking about there
he Carl Nakamura lost day-one three-zip
to his opponent Magnus week by Carlos
week by and day to force the day three
tiebreaker and and he Carl won that so
the fact that that be trails two and a
half half is not the case he's just
trailing by one day if he wins the sets
of games today well match is tight and
we they're off Peter 1.d4 by hobby
indeed
and Magnus's although we see him on his
screen apparently deep in thought as to
how to reply to this outrageous
beginning so we'll take this this moment
to to take a look at the game in which
we have more than one fly on the board
and Artemyev goes for the trump in this
particular game which is an interesting
option now these days unfortunately I
think you cannot really expect people to
be unprepared for the Trump it's very
much become part of the mainstream
opening discussion you no longer really
get raised eyebrows if you if you play
the trump even at the very top level
Magnus played it in the World
Championship match and it's generally
being played at the very very elite
levels by by many players and young goes
for one of the more principled lines I
feel d4 Knight f6 Bishop g5 the
immediate d5 III c5 which is I think one
of the more direct ways of trying to
equalize on the sport against the Trump
post game takes takes c4 is what our
team you've chose G takes c4 bishop
takes c4 I'm curious to see if after she
takes d4 his intention is maybe to play
Knight of 3 but that's probably a little
bit too adventurous right he probably is
setting a nasty little trap there yeah
but unfortunately you can't really
expect Yan to to blunder that and also
another three does allow Queen a5 check
and you may never win that phone back
again afterward saying I beat you to g3
fe 3 and e cigs I'm not sure I can prove
this is enough compensation for the
sacrifice pawn and so I suspect I
suspect after C d-four there's really
nothing wrong with just recapturing back
but generally speaking I think this is
quite an attractive position for white
in a in a much situation where you need
to play for a win because it's quite
unbalanced and also objectively looks
like it might be quite good for white
after something along the lines of 96
Knight of 3 and I don't know about the
ship g4 but if black develops
I don't know yeah as what would you say
is the normal development here he seeks
Bishop e7 logistic probably Bishop g7
and castles I guess yeah probably Bishop
g7 and castles I just want to point out
an old favorite trap of mine
for those of you who don't know that it
goes Bishop g4 in that moment after
knight c6 Knight f3 I mean I think
everybody should be familiar with this
one
d5 95 double question mark Knight takes
e5 whoopsie-daisy
didn't I just slightly it's slightly
unfair for me to point this out to you
here but in this particular case this
doesn't lose because of Queen 85 check
everything but the theme is but the
theme is actually very important III
appreciate you you mention is because
perhaps some of our viewers aren't
familiar with this tactic and of course
the the tactical motif yessir was
describing is this Bishop takes d1
Bishop b5 and because of how strongly
925 is and how few squares black has you
end up losing a lot of material here
exactly yeah but the importance of
calculating intermediate moves is also
something that you should all be paying
attention to and in this particular
position Queen a5 check I think means
that blood gets a very playable position
just to complete the thought now that
you play Queen a5 check after move like
93 you can actually I was calculating
you can actually do that I think yeah 95
check and game actually continues it
might be playable for y4 over you know
which is quite remarkable right King d8
Knight takes f7 check yeah and the game
rages on absolutely so it's unclear
position but we're getting a little bit
too carried away and some moves have
come in alright in fact the knight has
not been developed a 3 it's been
developed to e2 after Bishop g7 93 96
Vladislav preferred Knight G to castles
castles Bishop g4 and he has just played
g4 g5 in this position not entirely sure
what I think about any of this it's a
it's a very unusual structure I'd
think I've seen the structure very much
at all for from any of the openings I've
ever looked at in my life well so it
turns out that actually this is one of
my very favorite structures as black it
comes from a branch Dean
caro-kann where you take on e4 on move
three go Knight f6 the guy takes on on
Essex and I recapture with the Jeep on
and I get this kind of yes thank you
Peter for putting this up
I've always so just associated this
particular line with then Larson and
David Bronstein I hope I'm giving them
the proper credit and I try to do things
like I don't know Bishop f5 and Bishop
g6 and Bishop g7 as I mentioned many
many times all I wanted to say yeah III
appreciate it but what I meant is ya not
the kingside structure but specifically
the skin-side structure are in
conjunction with there not being
anything on the C file in the white bone
on the farm that particular
constellation of bones I don't quite
know what to think of I do like young
playing Bishop g4 early on because as
you mentioned if that Bishop gets
transferred over to g6 and then somehow
doesn't get picked up by 4 or 5 which is
quite relevant exactly it's a it's a
nice square because it covers some of
the slight weaknesses black might have
on the kingside there right and then you
say to yourself well what's happening to
that darts where a bishop it might poke
its head out on on h6 it's kind of
ironic
Peter that we had Camille on our show
twice as a special guest and you know
the moment that trump Oski appears on
the board
the very chasuble course that he did you
know where where's Camille when you need
him but okay you you you mentioned you
felt that that vladislav will be
satisfied because the thing is just a
very playable position yeah and this
play and there's play for both mm-hmm
yeah I don't know if white is better
expect probably not objectively but I
don't think he would necessarily care
about that at all because it's a sharp
position black really has no defined way
to you know simplify it right and
there's a lot of play left which is I
think something that vladislav in
particular likes to to get out of the
opening with the white pieces I think he
is very much in the camp of people who
aren't really greatly invested in the
idea of quote-unquote getting an
advantage and you know being better
after the opening he feels that he he is
a very strong player and as long as he
gets to play chess as long as this
doesn't devolve into into a memory
competition with some kind of a forced
outcome available to black I think he
feels very comfortable in those
situations everything completely
ignoring yeah I was about saying have we
gone past one-ply yeah we have gone past
one-ply and they are discussing what I
think is clearly becoming to my great
surprise originally but I've sort of
I've come to to have peace with it by
now that III and then Bishop d2 is more
or less a mainline reply to the names oh
these days when when I first realized
this was happening it it felt bizarre to
me honestly like I couldn't really
believe this is what I was watching
but then I had occasion to look at some
of it myself and also speak to people
have been doing this consistently and as
mentioned I am I'm much less outraged
now and Magnus goes for d5 Knight of 3
b6 which is definitely one of the more
concrete ways to to reply to this system
if I betrays the pawns goes Bishop d3
black occasionally goes for some c5 type
positions here but Magnus plays
something else goes Bishop a6 which i
think is a plan which generally is good
on positional grounds in any kind of NIM
Zoe's but it does misplace his
a little bit you the idea of trading the
very nice bishop on d3 for the bishop on
c8 is quite healthy but you do then have
to put your knight on a six and also the
Queen on c8 because you don't really
want to be trading on c3 just yet that's
probably not ideal but you do get you do
get an important pair of Bishops of the
board and the game continued a rupee one
rupee eight castles Bishop f8 92 are an
Magnus played RC 75 here again it feels
like fabbi is going to be a little bit
happy because he's got unbalanced game
and dynamic things that could happen
again that he's in a situation he has to
win today has to win on demand not this
game but just the complete sets of game
to tie up the match I'm going to
interrupt you Peter and just ask what's
trending I wanted to bring back Magnus
cos and sweet yes sir since you were
talking about what happened at the
lindoro said be the second leg of the
Magnus cross on chest or where Magnus
won 3-0 on the first day in his match
against Hikaru Nakamura and then went on
to lose the semi-finals against Hikaru
so he reminded himself with the
following tweet don't make the mistake
of relaxing too early again he said in a
relaxed manner tweeting this after he
won the first set in the quarterfinals
now against Fabiana so as you said very
much likely that Magnus would like to
win today set and then have a free day
instead of having to play on a third day
as well but he himself is aware that he
cannot fall into the same mistake as
what happened to him against high Carew
and on that note let me remind everybody
that we do have a question of the day so
that you can win today's course by Irvin
dummy if we can bring up the question
again our chess engines or AI useful for
studying chess
use the hashtag study chess if you would
like to interact with us and answer this
question please also explain if you say
yes or no why and if you use the engines
how do you think the best way is to
it's for studying chess I like to give a
shout that all of you tuning in on
twitch YouTube and chess 24 thousands of
you tuning in every single day it's a
thrill to have you and the interaction
in the live chats is absolutely a blast
I keep an eye on all three chats and on
that note I will now head back to my
behind the scenes spot looking at the
chat and social media and giving back
the voice - yes sir and Peter's to know
what's going on here with that isolated
phone structure between Khurana and
Carlson all right thank you very much
for that I was gonna say then we're
gonna have to give two prizes because I
think her win' already won his course by
answering the question of the day but
back to you Peter
after takes on c5 Knight takes d5 whites
Queen not the greatest choice of squares
of fab' chose c2 and no but I want to
say you you you've got to do something
with this Bishop on d2 you were alluding
to it very early in your explanation of
this opening that the bishop on tv2
isn't too happy but maybe it's very
happy right now Peter it's it's becoming
happier but black has a very good piece
play right now because the Queen only
six is surprisingly active keeping a
constant eye on this night only two and
after a three row case she ate white
would like to be able to play something
along the lines of Bishop d4 and then
perhaps Knight f4 and started backing
the 495 but as things our Bishop before
already invites something like 96 and it
becomes I think genuinely awkward for y2
to make me why am I saying 96 I mean 93
wins material on the spot there is a
there's a bigger threat here now and
also relevantly if y decides to go for
something like rook F do you on I think
you have to worry I don't know if worry
is the right word but you definitely
have to calculate Knight a for the line
takes d5 rook takes d5 we just take on
c3
twice and we take on a3
and as long as we don't get mated on the
King sights tonight yes but I don't
think I don't think we do get mated and
he reflects stabilizes if there's
nothing really bad happening to black on
on the Kings side and games start
looking quite rosy honestly because this
pair is is quite strong and this does
start looking like some kind of a very
very nice green field end game which is
obviously very dear to my heart
mm-hmm I was just being told that this
is that point we're looking at is from
Christoph so monkeys
chasuble course as well it's just really
remarkable I being we've had these chess
authors on on the show and then suddenly
they're playing the variations until
which moment I'm very curious yeah this
whole Bishop d2 complex this rudenstine
Bishop d2 is in detestable course where
it stops I'm not really too sure mm-hmm
you know I I was finding that same
position fascinating and because of that
sudden lights were barrage with with the
rook was on d5 and in fact they are
progressing along the along this path
but if I be chose to play rock CD blood
not rock everyone so we have the similar
position with with the rook on f1
instead of c1 okay very interesting and
assuming we were to go down that road
yeah and it it almost feels like you
know you want to just go 95 and rook d7
or you know some kind of combination
yeah but then after rook e7 I think it
fizzles that's the problem it does look
attractive for a second but then I I
couldn't find any way to really create
well anything tangible here well
especially we I'm staring at a back rank
mate by the way exactly yeah so I mean
it really feels like I can't play rook
d1 and get on with the business because
oops I've got issues myself okay so if
we can't
do this do we have to play a move like
c3 c4 I I have a feeling you might have
to but then once you start giving black
Tempe - yeah - stabilized I think it
does become an exercise in in damage
limitation more than anything else why
probably isn't doing so poorly but black
is also completely fine and we are all
the way up the queen takes a three on
the live board as well which is not
unexpected frankly it did seem like it
was it was quite likely to happen and c4
c4 played by him by farming yeah it's
really a pity that it didn't have a
enough follow-up but he that I mean
would it have made a difference if Abby
kept the rookin see the Ruben F was not
contributing that's clear I'm curious
why he chose why he chose Roxy d1 there
if what could have bothered him so much
after a cavity one that he chose not to
play it I'm not entirely sure there is
the move Knight b3 but I don't think
it's that great because I think we can
go Ruby Wan and also Queen takes b3
Queen takes it - and Bishop e1 appears
to be not bad at all so currently I'm a
little bit I'm a little bit mystified by
that choice but there must have been a
reason
alright fair enough and Peter let's have
a look at the other quarterfinals if you
will sure here up after Bishop d3 Yun
played rook c8 h3 Bishop d7 Artemi of
quite logically put the night on g3
hinting at trying to occupy perhaps the
h5 for the f5 squares black played Queen
b6 Queen h5 and now queen g4 which i
think is aimed at trying to get to f4
and G file let's say after okay g1 I'm
pretty sure the intention is to play
Queen a4 and then if the Queen continues
getting chased further the black Queen
goes to g5 which is not a bad square at
all you know something like 93 takes h5
would be great if you get there clean
away from for its
really acrimony I'm in something like we
need to something like we need to could
actually be a serious serious
consideration here with the intention of
playing Knight h5 next move another big
question I would have here as white is
what do we feel about this position
do we feel we we are better or not
I guess he maybe wants to play Queen d3
because allowing route 81 here looks
like then black doesn't really have a
good square for the Queen
so maybe Queen d3 aiming to either trade
the Queens or shift the Queen away from
a good at five square right it's funny
because I always think of this Bishop on
g7 is really wanting to a shift and take
over another diagonal if you just put
that position on the board Peter that
that you had their moment ago and
instead the move Queen d3 I'm thinking
Bishop h6 swishy southern Queen a four
is also yes yes something weird like
that
and you know my spidey sense were
tingling there if you could play Knight
D Knight c3 d4 just a moment you know I
did spy upon on b2 that was one reason
why I was thinking to keep my Queen on
d4 shame on me I know I know I know but
there you have it
I think things B to d6 might actually
become very risky exactly
might be hoisted on my own petard
therefore and actually after Queen d3
even here I blood nerd 94 to begin with
it might not be playable at all for
black because this looks very dodgy
followed up by rock 81 and then perhaps
d6
oh good play I'm beginning to actually
quite like Knight a5 in this position
I'm interested in what vladislav will
settle on perhaps he is looking at
something even more aggressive but not
the Fife is definitely a very playable
move here well and it actually does
completely force more or less yeah black
black could maybe play Queen before but
then why have we played Queen d4 in the
previous move that would make very very
little sense precisely precisely and
here
rook left rook the rover after night of
five and Queen before rook e1 to e4 kind
of just have to plays itself I would ya
bloody Slough why stuff started with
Bishop c2 which is also an interesting
option I think it proms 96 model
anything else and I can I can definitely
get behind the idea of forcing 936 and
now in particular I'm interested in the
idea of playing Bishop a5 not 9:00 to
5:00 to get the bishops off the board
first and then that night on a5 will be
extremely difficult to shift yeah if you
if you imagine some kind of a position
like this black really lacks any way at
all to interact with this night on a5
really at least for the time being so
this position is is quite dangerous I
would say for for yawn well in
absolutely agree and the black minor
pieces the knight on g6 in the bishop on
g7 make a very sorry impression against
it's very powerful Knight on f5 and as
you say I mean that's an attack for free
that and this is what he's gone for Yun
quickly plays rook e8 and I was almost
attempted to suggest heresy I know it
oh I can't play a six and sacrifice upon
there's a rookie one problem that yeah
there's something I don't think with the
Queen on g4 black is ready to open up
the team I'll just yeah apart at all not
at all at all there should be seven Ruby
seven played Knight a5 v I imagine the
Queen goes to be four to at least try to
tie up one rook to the protection of the
b2 b2 pawn but now the other option
would be to play Queen f4 and hopefully
Queen g5 but same idea different concept
Queen d2
yeah Queen d2 actually does both yeah
that's okay that's a good suggestion
thank you very much unless we have
worried about getting mated about after
94 but I don't think we are I think we
are reasonably okay with picking up
I love the white bones maybe the one on
g5 is more important yeah I like windy
too I think of the moves we discuss
Queen d2 is easily the strongest one and
back to our number one versus number two
are our nimzo-indian and it seems to be
really does look like a green pill
doesn't it it does have it with a by the
way I excuse me let me just correct it a
very good group excellent groom Phil yes
yeah yeah I'm trying to figure out if I
feel like black is already much better
or just you know slightly more pleasant
after Queen c5 I think maybe rooks even
still holds on somehow because we would
like to play b6 b5 but my taste before
I've exists mm-hmm and a six queen a
four is a little bit awkward
you can play Bishop g7 but after Bishop
g7 I thought there is some ideas like
Queen a4 hoping for some math
simplifications and perhaps black
survives whatever I see why it's not
black black happy with a six we need for
b5 unhappy no but I don't think I think
these positions generally tend to be
whole double clearly black is better but
I think I think white why probably does
something like Queen b5 here and starts
chasing and if it's the end game the end
game probably ends up being just very
comfortable for white even because the
King comes in and the White King is
quite quite a lot closer to the pawn on
c4 then the black is agreed and after
Queen c7 even even let's say if I
centralized with 25 if I already feel
like it shouldn't be so bad maybe I'm
understating the problems a little bit
but okay I need to play rook c3 first to
make sure the pawn doesn't reach the c3
square you probably play something like
Bishop g7 and I play 25 and then I start
playing age four and then King Jiwon Kim
G - Kim Jiwan King G - and claim that my
pieces now are quite well coordinated
and not much bad can happen to me here
so not to rush the action with a 6 b5
but to build up if you will yeah Peter
would recommend - yeah Magnus played
Bishop g7 first two which Fabi replied
with might be five queenie 1784 and a
five
if black ends up having i think like
with very much like of course in any
kind of an endgame like the one we just
discussed to have his eye his pastor on
the a file not the see file because that
would in particularly in conjunction
with the bishop on g7 that would present
a much bigger threat to to white but it
still feels to me like this is probably
a controllable position for far be he's
not going to enjoy playing it but it
feels to me like he probably ends up
ends up saving it in the long run now
even though yes like after twenty six
it's clear which side you should be
preferring 26 or quincy far i feel and i
don't know why i play 26 25 is perhaps a
much more straightforward way to try and
get the type of a position you want to
get why probably just goes something
like night of three or 92 i don't know
which one is stronger yeah I was always
aspiring in such positions to get my
Knight to d5 so this is why I mention
that I dig out cuz right yeah night at
four yeah I understand exactly what
you're talking about there Peter when a
moment ago we had a passed pawn on the C
file now black aspiring yes specifically
let's discuss this for a second if we
get an endgame like this if black
already had the rook on c8 and could
let's say rook c8 King G guru k-8 right
this is a very unpleasant and iam I I'm
not going to say it's lost but this is a
very very unpleasant endgame for white
to try and hold but the issue is of
course white goes through K six in this
position yeah and black is if black goes
for the direct approach here of trading
c4 for b6 like that it he
will not be able to stop the white rogue
from assuming the the correct square on
a six or a eight and then it will be
very difficult for black to win which I
guess is why Magnus says I don't need to
hurry with any of this for now and goes
green d6 very very very interesting
situation from I really like the that
the play of the players I mean again in
a 15-minute game they are playing a
rapid game and yet the quality of this
game and that understanding of not
playing a6 b5 and trying to go for a
pawn that's that's deep but I mean I'm
really impressed that the players played
at such a high level with little to no
time mm-hmm and I think the the reason
for Queen t6 in particular is that 92
right now runs into Queen d3 which is
actually very difficult to face
comfortably three things are suddenly
hanging and why probably ends up losing
material here and that probably prompts
white to play Knight f3 but it's much
harder for Fabi I think to find good
squares for that night to go further
from from me to you had the idea as
yessir already pointed out of landing in
25 eventually maybe calling it an idea
is a little bit optimistic White has a
dream a dream of landing it on d5 one
day whereas from a three it really isn't
going anywhere at all it's a little bit
of a Foursquare can try to take a
tactical approach to Abby's mounting
problems rook d5 with the idea perhaps
that Bishop takes d4 d5 and hoping that
I haven't lost some material that's all
that's interesting but I was going to
suggest that that yeah when he said a
tactical solution I actually wanted to
bring up something that 5e actually
ended up doing okay is Queen b3 in this
ties in very well with something you
said not today but on one of the
previous broadcasts when you
we're talking about the incredible
importance are in particulate high
levels of understanding and trusting
yourself to properly handle basic end
games and Fabi
I looked at this for two to three
minutes and he thought to himself with
the bishop still alive and on the board
this appears to be a very unpleasant
endgame I am not entirely sure I will
draw so let's just sacrifice a pawn here
with Queen b3 I was I was about to
suggest Queen b5 I think it comes to the
same I think black probably ends up
having to go for it
I mean takes b6 here black takes we take
black takes on c4 we go rotations and I
think for somebody who is not very
confident in his in his endgame skills
taking a position like this with white
and driving it towards a rookin game
where your opponent has a healthy extra
pawn is a decision that will not come
very naturally mm-hmm but it's a
decision that needs to be in your
arsenal because it's very very possible
and I was leaning towards that way
myself it's very possible that this is
just the absolute best way practically
to make sure you make a draw in this
position and the yes after some thought
Magnus does end up taking on d4 so we're
going to see this end game in mind and I
of course am loath to hand over on
unless you know and absolutely forced to
Queen b3 Bishop takes d4 d1 here kind of
a similar here my Ruby 555 and actually
actually this is sir there's a nun this
but why hasn't he done this huh
interesting
they're pregnant pause
I assumed I was I was I'm still trying
to figure out if I can convince myself
black is somehow winning in this endgame
but he isn't I think it's just a draw so
yeah I don't see anything particularly
wrong with this to be honest and the
speech I gave has kind of been borne out
by what Fabi ended up playing but I I
don't quite know why I enjoy
tremendously I was like I'm learning a
lot he well I'm coaching I'm quoting you
directly interesting that they've gotten
the precise rook and pawn ending that
you were thinking that Abby is confident
that he can draw but after after I said
that I started thinking I think it's
supposed to be a reasonably comfortable
draw if that rook is on a 2 but when
when that truck is protecting the pawn
from the side not not from in front of
the pawn how easy over draw is it
because well just to just to reiterate
this position is a tricky draw with them
when the phone is on the V file but
there's supposed to be a reasonably
comfortable technical draw when the
phone is on the a file and the way
people tend to play it for a win is once
again I'm just drawing a schematic here
it's clearly a lot more a lot more
intricate than that but just to show the
general plan eventually you have to give
up something on the Kings side
preferably the King needs to be closer
to the a3 poem but I just don't have the
patience to generate another ten empty
moves here and then you go rooks even
rotate seven rooks III and then the King
starts running toward towards the before
square and in in the current situation
on the board the rook is already
attacking the pawn from from the side so
after King f8 let's say if Y sort of
sleeps on the job and goes Kingi to King
e7 and continues passing
now I'm taking the seven followed by
King c7 and king b7 I think it becomes
rather scary for our for white but
there's a she just goes rook c1 R okay
once but completely invalidating
everything I was saying and I think what
you were just saying was spot-on
I think that frankly if you could just
go to that position where white was
sleeping on the job as you put it the
rook was on c4 this is a very important
chest technical knowledge King me seven
yeah I think the reason he's gone rooks
you want okay one just to interrupt you
is because ruk a7 exists okay because
the king the King doesn't actually get
to those good squares so easily if you
if you want to go towards the rook you
have to do it all along the back rank
giving white a lot of time to do
something so I suspect this is the
reason
Magnus ended up not not going for that
but okay your point was if let's say we
get here yes so what but the point I
just wanted to make is that very often
you get this situation we go like king
d7 there's yeah let's just say yeah
Roche at something like what your yeah
King rook takes King b5 we take say age
seven and eight three and after rook a7
yes exactly that was what I wanted you
to draw was that this is a very
important motif that you need to know
that you can make a bridge for your look
okay but Magnus has gone for the rook in
front of this on
he's also played a3 and I always thought
that this is a very easy draw now what
do you think winning scheme that Magnus
could possibly happen Mike for example
after white plays the move for g5 I
honestly don't quite know one thing that
perhaps once again for for some of our
viewers who may not be aware of this it
may look to them like this is clearly a
winning position you play too
and then the King comes to be three and
then you play Ruby one and white resigns
that is ng5 has been played if you play
a two you might as well just offer a
draw because what ends up happening is
even let's say white releases the king
and then the King runs runs towards the
the pony - and at the very last moment
the rope goes all the way up to a eight
and starts shaking starts shaking from
the side and drives the King away from
the eight supona and then goes back to a
eight
it's a and that position cannot really
cannot really be won at all but if you
keep the pawn on a three of course it's
not that easy because black will have
the a to square to try and hide the King
away if he ends up deciding for for a
king run there but yeah I don't know it
seems to me like once again of course
King f8 has been met in the game by the
move rope a7 so exactly if Magnus
decides to go for this he will have to
actually creep along the the
eighth-ranked here play King G a truck
f7 let's say rook c1 as I described and
his King is so far away from the a file
and the a3 pawn in general that Y should
be able to generate just enough count to
play on the other side of the board if
you if we imagine let's say we continue
the Lion King h2 King g8 rook takes f7
leg goes rook c1 ruk a7 rooks e3 and
here we go
f4 King c8 h v this feels to me like
there should be there's never going to
be enough time for black to to be able
to to pressure the white rook into
anything because there's going to be a
passer on the King side and in just
about the very immediate future which
will generally speaking be enough for
for a draw in in pretty much every
single case and uh King J played by
Magnus he still runs zero risks of
course but I also don't quite see where
his winning chances are coming from here
well let's lop that con off rook takes
f7 and we got to start with that one
that's a that's a no-brainer
and then I'm assuming king c8 because
rook c1 and I just wanted to point out
that the immediate rook c1 yeah good
night captain
thank you can I take another one no I
don't be a 2 a 1 right at that sauce no
no I want I'm sorry Peter Brooke at a 7
they've already uh the Magnus sort of
showed his hand there he played after
King d8 rook takes f7 he played rook f1
but now if I be played through k7 rook F
- King g3 and it feels like this is now
just a very very obvious draw because if
you play rook a to here I think what can
quite safely take on a 7 and then return
salutely absolutely at the point that I
wanted me you know was that after say
rook c1 like a rookie sac
I'm then location 7 yeah yeah yeah sorry
I'm going I mean I came in there but it
doesn't look like this is a dead dead
draw now I don't think Abby has any
worries in the game position after this
game g3 I think I think like a sane sane
solution here is to actually go rook a
five or rook f8 or somewhere just don't
even go rotate so because yeah I just
don't think black is playing for a win
here anymore okay - okay seven I think
it's time for you to start running
towards the G file because if you
continue insisting eventually h5 g hg 6
might beat you precisely like if you if
you look at this position and you and
you continue insisting you are better
like eventually you will have to start
looking looking for precise ways to draw
and yeah Magnus goes up goes rope a 1
and a 2 which of course is still a very
comfortable draw for everybody but the
result was never really in doubt for a
while now I don't like Magnus is
technique here in this game I think that
that moment when his rook was on c4 and
he decided to plan it on a1 that
was really throwing away a future if you
will I do think it was a better idea to
first of all include the move h7 h5 for
black and then go on his journey over to
the queenside it wasn't to be a draw and
that game was already decided let's go
to the other quarterfinals match Peter
yeah and here are there at some point
has been there have been much
simplifications and it seems like the
players are potentially repeating moves
as well we left it somewhere around here
you're a very strong move Queen d2 has
actually been played and game continued
in g4 Roxie d8h for Queen a foreign
Queen h3 and here Jana I think
absolutely correctly estimated that he
needs to start driving that piece away
he played his cheeks and vladislav went
for for this position where the black
king is slightly compromised but his
pieces frankly look more active than the
white pieces which prompted artemiev to
trade all the rooks and then activate
his Knight at the price of the B to pawn
this looks scary but the knight on g6
provides enough cover so that there is
no immediate mate and while it's love
has been playing this pawn down position
for a win for a while now repeating I
guess to gain some time and then
continuing to play on this is the
current position I think white runs
close to zero risk here but I also think
he very rarely actually ends up tricking
his opponent enough to win okay I do
speak in favor of the smoke III g4
though because you are taking the f5
square under control Peter and on a very
good day you know I mean Knight a5 check
might be bothersome you I mean the extra
pollen
give me a percentage mention maybe we
have time enough to pick up one i7 and
my first instinct was why can't we just
play king g6 but I think allowing Queen
e8 check might might be well by risky I
mean
because I think the only move here that
allows no Forks is King g7 then check
and after King h6 white I think wins the
night with Queen takes e7 and then night
at five yet which is why young played
aged five which is also a move I was
considering but I don't quite know what
he isn't I guess he found some kind of a
perpetual after gh I guess he just
starts giving checks like Queen g5 and
then kicking g5 and so on and on a
completely open board it does feel like
this prob'ly ends up being a draw right
and that Knight f5 check is a so as a
way of meeting h5 I think we go king e7
and the the pawn endgame is not very
wide because a6 and b5 happens very very
quickly so uh I was thinking sorry Peter
I was thinking 97 Queen c7 Queen d5
check I was thinking I'm hoping that my
1/4 on neutralizes that side but it
still is a queen end game 3 against Mary
right so you don't really have a very
high expectation of converging this and
Yun somewhat surprisingly played after
gh not Queen g5 check between d5 check
and not Octavia plate of three and he
will have the option of the Queen g5
check now playing queen g4 and
continuing the game even though I feel
like it's probably still a draw this
difficult when it happened and now we
can probably just take and go something
like ninety five ninety three and
eventually all the Queen side comes off
and two against one on one flank is
never going to be too problematic for
for young here I totally agree that
looks like a draw in that night aiming
for four well I mean it was a promising
start Peter the positions were
double-edged
imbalance in particular I thought that
Ladislav I liked his Bishop fi treatment
and his winning control of the FIO f v
square I'm sorry
but I didn't bring in success not not
entirely yeah we expect this game to
finish in a draw right like Ian's
decision not even to take on g4 for now
keeping keeping his options slightly
more open yes and again as just a
reminder to everybody we are in the day
two of the quarterfinals in the groups a
and B matches and yon and Magnus both
have a lead they won their first set of
matches on day one sure those Victor's
win again today they will be in the
semi-finals
there was four players who will be
eliminated in the quarterfinals will go
home with 8000 bucks that it's much
better to progress in the event and get
to the semifinals where you're
absolutely a little extra fifteen
thousand one hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in total prizes being splashed
around amongst our 12 participants who
started the event sorry Peter this game
sure looks like yeah it's I'm keeping it
updated but we all know how it ends kind
of thing a fourth king h6 played and now
white will take on g5 look we'll take on
g5 v go Knight c8 and everything comes
off I'm gonna interrupt you and suggest
that since this is a draw we'll watch
the players go go perfunctory this drawn
position let's go to honor and thank you
yes sir it is indeed this very game from
which I chose the learning moment of the
round even though the game ended in a
draw I do think that the maneuver that
Yasser and Peter were highlighting is
very instructive and something that any
club player can learn from if you look
at Vice position here it looks like
there's not much going on in terms of
attacking chances but after Knights to
g3 suddenly white is regrouping their
pieces
and the idea is the following the Queen
will end on age five and we would like
our night on f5 Artem you have carried
this out perfectly by if we show the
next few moves in the game nopal
mushiya's answer and Queen to h5 and
then the game continued with nikomia she
activating their queen and this is the
case where I think it's very tempting
for any player begin their copy Cup
player to jump to a5 right away with the
night because it's a beautiful spot but
if you think that you you do want to
keep that night then we need to come up
with a different strategic plan and find
a way in which we can eliminate first a
d7 Bishop and then have that beautiful
post on f5 for the night and the
maneuver is indeed what artemiev carried
out in the game perfectly executed
Bishop to c2 - then place the bishop on
a5 you want to trade the light square
Bishop and in this way we will have that
very strong post for the night on a5 we
can show the next few moves and how many
Palmilla she defended very well by
playing group to d8 trade on d7 Knight
f5 and here a crucial move Queen to d2
the Queen is a very strong defensive
piece and by playing Queen to d2 and
Queen g5 and upon me she made sure that
his King will be safe but I promise you
if you try this strategic idea how
beautifully and powerfully artemyev has
managed to maximize the potential of his
species on the King side this should
work against club players and so
sometimes super grandmasters defend
better and as you can see a 2720 almost
2800 Union partnership with the black
pieces did find Queen d2 Queen GFI but I
bet it will not happen at every single
Club tournament so this was a beautiful
very educational moment in my opinion
and now back to what's going on for the
rest of the quarterfinals yes sir thank
you very much on a very nice moment
indeed in fact what we're going to do is
we're going to take a commercial break
we just had the first game and what
promises to be
or rapid games and once again in case
those games are tight we'll be going to
blitz a pair of blitz games lots of
exciting action please stay tuned we'll
see on the other side of this commercial
break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there are more moves in chess than atoms
in the universe
only one moves ends again
[Music]
[Music]
my name is John Bartholomew and this is
the checkmate patterns manual hello
everyone and welcome back to our live
coverage of the chest bone masters I
hope you enjoyed of the first games as
we get prepared for games - in these
quarterfinals Magnus Carlsen defended
beautifully with the black pieces and
it's incumbent upon his opponent Fabiano
to literally win on demand he must win
today fabbi
or he is eliminated theater that was a
very impressive game by the world
champion my good I think so yeah I was
only mildly curious by your choice of
the word defended because he was yes
only only attack for most of it and and
came at some point it looked to me like
he had very significant chances of
actually you know jumping to avert or
and early lead and sort of breaking the
serve if we continue the tennis analogy
had he won the first game with the black
pieces I think Bobby would have been in
extremely dire straits but well joy
still is still fine and the match
continues from from a neutral videos is
with a will equal scores yeah I can't I
figure out how to continue continue that
sentence somewhat unassuming
continuation chosen by Magnus here and
actually the the structure we might see
very soon here will be the exact same
structure they've had in the previous
game only with colors reversed which is
not something you see very often these
days I think
yeah and isolated Queen on but this kind
of a Tarrasch which is kind of
interesting because we we do have a
special guest who will be joining us at
chess will offer dear friend of mine
Erwin Lonnie erlin has just been
doing a course on the dubov tarush I
don't think this is the dew blush no
this is loud today Tara the worst Irish
is a lot less thing yeah as that this
isolated Queen pond my first impressions
has always been that when black is the
one you know hosting the isolated queen
pawn White's extra half tempo if you
will in this position in particular
favors white what's been your impression
here it's definitely a slightly more
pleasant position to play with white but
generally from my feeling is if the
black ends up trading the LightSquared
bishop as early as it happened here and
has the Knights on f6 and c6 honestly
I'm a lot more familiar with these with
these types of positions from the French
where the pawn would be on c3 not on e3
and that changes things quite a bit
because for instance the the long
diagonal would not have been available
to white here as comfortably as it will
be in the game well but that particular
material balance
I've come to to believe that black isn't
really suffering they're greatly
you do often have to defend some rather
boring endgame ish positions which like
is is definitely not my cup of tea if we
talk about my personal preferences but I
know Magnus is taking a half moment if
you will he's considering maybe Bishop
a3 Oh something happened there very
quickly when he played b3 and Fabi chose
to take everything off on d4 action
prior to the to the moment that white
could play either Bishop e3 and Bishop
b2 and now Bishop d6 Bishop b2 castles
yeah on the board and I think black is
intending to play something like rook e8
Bishop e5 and this is the boring ish
position I was referring to if you will
but if you imagine the dark square the
squared bishops are coming off here
which i think is not an unreasonable
expectation these positions with
the the major pieces left and one pair
of Knights they are not necessarily any
kind of fun for black at all but I don't
think you lose them very very often
although Magnus Magnus I'm sure will be
quite happy to to play a position where
he runs absolutely no risks whatsoever
and on a good day might create problems
well it's a specialist specificity
especially I'll work on that one this
specific position Peter at Knight c3
threatens Knight takes d5 and there's a
checkmate on g7 hanging so not I'm not
planning to recapture on d5 but rather
ago so it for example rook e8 95 I'm not
falling for Bishop h2 check you can't
actually I was wondering about that
because you can take here because Knight
text if I clean takes g7 as a problem
yes therefore therefore if black wants
to do that he needs to he needs to go
for this position and she is genuinely a
little bit worse for black after let's
say takes takes Andrew kept g1 followed
by ok she won this is a patented my
magnus carlsen grind I agree with that
yeah so after Knight c3 perhaps Europe
advice to play Queen e6 and that we
intentionally blame Bishop e5 next move
right I wanted to play Knight d5 and I
wanted to play a game of give me the
better minor piece I wanted to take the
bishop on a d6 it permitted ya 95 is a
lot more awkward than I thought
originally because I mean I can play
Bishop b8 but I'm not gonna say I'm very
happy about that prospect in particular
because after okay c1 I might not have a
good reply 297 next move right things
aren't really going entirely according
to plan alright and Fabi I think white
quite reasonably is now thinking because
it's probably an important choice that
he is about to make here right as you
say if Black gets in the most work e8
Bishop e5 is okay no
problem I mean you neutralize the
pressure on the diagonal the d5 pawn
he'd be weak but it's just that this
very specific position does present an
awkward question to black how is he
dealing with you know queenie 695 that
could be an issue or ninety five and did
you figure it i think he has a he has
settled on rookie eight and i was
excited
of the two slightly worse positions we
were discussing i think that endgame
probably is the one you choose because i
think you're reasonably comfortable you
shouldn't be losing it if you play
properly and queenie six not be five I
really didn't like at all right a 19-5
Bishop h2 was our advice and you know
those bishops versus Knights positions
we we've had some questions and what's
the most underrated piece of advice or
overrated piece of advice what's your
view Bishop versus Knight pawns on both
flanks Bishop favors night by a big
margin Peter
or is that an overrated is that a myth
no I think it is it is a resin or a
reasonably large margin in particularly
in a position like this where a knight I
mean if black already had the knight on
c6 and did not relinquish control over
the open D file it would have been fine
but the knight is some way away from it
and if you if you have if you end up
having to play some move like might be
six where the knight really has no
future whatsoever I think it's just not
great honestly III don't think you I
don't think you enjoy that at all the
same thing we have left off in the other
match as well made an interesting choice
by Artemyev to the rule office not the
most common at top level chess yeah this
nine or something I think it was team
war timur raja baath was champions at
the time which they were used to play a
lot of a lot of Janish at one point
then he gravitated away away from it
because I think once the the novelty so
to speak wears off a little bit it
becomes a lot a lot less easy to play
but to my knowledge it hasn't really
been refuted yet as such it's you know
it's just an opening which I think
justifiably has a bit of a dodgy
reputation it's not supposed to be
entirely correct but well the way yon is
playing against it is the way I always
like to play against it I always felt
that for d3 is if it works sort of
exactly what I would like to be doing
against the yen is playing for
understanding more than more than for
some kind of memorization and there is a
lot of memorization if you start talking
about these lines where nine thirty six
and even d5 if I fist not really
supposed to be any good but the most
still exists and it still requires
attention and it's really not that easy
to prove black is doing so poorly and in
case you know if you talk about computer
analysis for instance perhaps the
machines just reviewed it outright but
how easy is it to reproduce those those
computer lines is a big question where
is d3 you get positions where just as in
the game let's say you get positions
where black has compromised his King
site to a certain degree the bishop will
normally have a very nice life on the a
goo-gaa diagonal for white and if you
imagine some sort of a position like
castles Bishop c4 check King h8 95 Queen
e8 and perhaps even maybe F 2 F 4 here
why does get a lot of very nice kind of
active piece play here and I always
enjoyed it but of course things are
never that easy and in particular the
move Bishop g4 you always have to have a
good reaction to a Peter if I can su is
sailing in question and there's a to a
[ __ ]
fit in white's strategy yeah I've never
actually seen that move before it
surprised me how quickly unplayed this I
think when I was looking at the the same
issue were supposed to play something
else in that position I'm trying to
remember exactly what because I I
definitely studied this position when I
was for some reason it fascinated me
when I was really really young like when
I was maybe 14 15 I remember spending
quite some time looking at this and
being quite fascinated by it but before
a four didn't really feature very large
you know my very limited look-see I
always featured Queen D 323 seem to be a
recurrent theme in many of the lines I
looked at I can't recall an a2 a4 in any
of my variations but I mean modern chess
these days and the chess engine you know
you show me a TA for I scratch my head
and the final mutton don't work yeah I I
don't I don't really disagree uh the one
thing I will say is that perhaps it
lengthens the potential A to G a
diagonal which means that the bishop on
c4 will be much harder to chase down for
black because it will have the the 8 2
square available to it as well but yeah
it feels it feels like it's just the
people these days just firmly believe
that a4 in all kinds of Spanish /
[Music]
Italian positions it's just beneficial
to you so so they just go with that and
what happened after a for Peter
after a for Bishop g4 queen d3 is on the
board and I think castles is as usual
the most critical question here because
black at some point does need to commit
to getting the King out of the center 27
long long castles just doesn't seem
feasible here you're pinning yourself a
little bit too much and I think I think
it's just time to bite the bullet and
play and play play short castles well it
was funny that you said that because
right on cue I was about to say look I'm
losing this match
being gifted an opportunity to have
Kings on opposite flanks those types of
middle games I think are some of the
most challenging so Queen d7 I agree I'm
kind of walking to multiple pins there
but you know how can I resist playing
such a complex position when I'm behind
in the match is it to greater risk
that's I guess in particular I think
what I dislike about it is that I can
white can play five I don't think you
can allow a six having pinned yourself
on this diagonal and after a six [ __ ]
play for like if you're cussing if
you're cussing queenside here you're
really castling straight into it
b4 b5 becomes a topic after 95 I don't
even know what you're supposed to play
on the states
yes feels like it might it might lead to
positions which will be beyond repair
and yeah I understand
and very much endorsed your your idea of
sharpening things up because our team if
does need have been a win in it in
today's set but right losing Game two
with black will not really advance his
cause very far now with your moves a
four a five and nineteen 3d5 I gotta
tell you Peter you're really hurting
blacks feelings there because that
that's that's what I wanted to
demonstrate here that it's not just it's
not just my my kind of general dislike
for the idea of consoling along here
game since there have been some updates
and I'm not really liking this position
for phobia unfortunately okay let's take
a switch over or Peter Magnus making
progress well what I was saying about
the knight needing to be on c6.r is I
think something that influenced by this
decision to play ninety seven here but I
don't know if there was necessarily
missed or not but he after a key seven I
just realized that ninety six which is
what I was expecting
straight up losses to room G for the
game kind of ends here because the black
position suddenly collapses King sight
the King side is just falling
part so he had to go night to five
instead and that is just not a
particularly good square for this night
in particular after Lucca for I'm not
even sure where this night is supposed
to go honestly it's really simply
gruesome I mean okay here maybe I can
struggle on with Knight d6 but what
about rook G for Peter and main there's
a double hit
I can I can count on f6 would be hanging
after up d4 but also b7 singing so yeah
I just I just don't like this position
that's all and Luca for it's probably
not even the only not even the only way
to play here I suspect there are other
choices as well yeah rook g4 was my
choices yeah Ruby for Ruby for I was
planning to play it on the next move I
was trying to drive drive the night away
and then go Ruby for really cash in but
even the immediate or g4 is very very
unpleasant with threatening the pawn on
f6 with threatening the PO number 7 as
the other cell and also a very simple
threat of e3 e4 is now we're top yeah
maybe h5 but after h5 of g6 black
continues kind of struggling to find
moves because King h7 rook takes f6 is
completely unplayable due to the pin on
the seventh rank it really does feel as
if the position might be close to lost
here for Fabi which is a very striking
development as I as I said the end game
starting from here is not fun nobody
would ever describe this as being as
being fun for black but I really did not
expect it to go this poorly well indeed
after rook b8 rumty 4f6
rook c1 the only thing I'm thinking is
there was some calculation mistake
because the position that I'm seeing on
the board after Knight f5 I mean both
your move rook f4 roof g4 I mean this is
horrifying yeah the only thing you you
probably don't have to do is to take on
the 8 and take on b7 because that
actually gives black a very very decent
count
laughter - even then even this position
might in some cases be dangerous but you
definitely want to do more or less
anything else but that agree yeah and
Magnus I think is just enjoying the
choice here I think the move hasn't been
played yet specifically because the
choice is so pleasant and we have
absolutely stuff in the second one oh
yeah by the way on Magnus board this one
blew up we ate f7 appears to be after
Queen t3 he did Castle Yan as expected
played Bishop c4 check in 95 but after
Queenie 896 is a very natural move here
but it may have been a very serious
miscalculation because our team if quite
quite more or less instantly replied
with night before the Queen has to go to
some unfortunate squares because the
bishop on g4 is still alive you cannot
go to e2 you cannot go to g1 we need to
plate and now Queen f7 and of course the
point here is that after Knight takes a
faith Queen takes e4 tonight on the fate
might be just go on for all intents and
purposes and yeah that would that would
spell that would spell disaster for for
yan here and right I don't quite see how
you're supposed to avoid it if we're
honest with ourselves in well even if
we're dishonest with ourselves a
disaster looks like yah an overreach
there that move as you described it the
natural move Mikey sakes looks like it
has a stone-cold reputation to it Queen
f7 turning the tables Knight F Knight c7
Queen c4 Knight a8 two minor pieces for
rook and pawn but those minor pieces
they look wonderful Peter yeah this this
cannot be the solution imagine I think
is you can quite safely describe a
simply lost for for white I mean there
is still some life in it but you you
almost never expect to be able to
survive this
surely I agree and especially the knight
on e4 and just just the beautiful open
Sicilian kind of position for for that
Vladislav of win by the way is what he
needs today not just in this game but in
all the sets today turning to Magnus
I've just seen this move rook g6 the
very yeah that's that's the position we
were describing room k4h 546 I honestly
don't know how you survived this with
black perhaps you play something like
rook c8 and you start chasing the second
rope hoping to catch the rock on g6 in
the end but that shouldn't work at rook
c8 rugby sevens rugby a I understand how
miserable this is but and obviously just
Bishop takes f6 probably is just
completely winning right yes takes d8
and now this rook is free to to get to
a6 and white is just two pawns up with a
better position as they as they say well
as comedian Jackie Gleason said how
sweet it is to pawns up in the better
position oh that's not a solution and
well otherwise if you allow III for you
will just get mated I think that's the
the biggest issue here black faces here
is that if you allow for your position
will just completely collapse there will
be nothing left so for example rook d2
you don't even have to bother with
Bishop f6 you're saying rookie to e4 and
you just get made it before yeah here I
think Bishop takes f6 is probably not a
mistake but the form is is potentially
stronger as well yeah I don't mind that
I don't mind that one bit you don't mind
it looks like aa Rabi you know you fell
out of bed this morning this looks
absolutely yeah the game sort of
continues after OB through CAF cool at
zero g g7 King h8 but yeah you you have
very very low expectations of surviving
this with the black pieces normally Fabi
has gone
d88 which is stopping 3/4 and also at
least hoping to play rookie 7 next move
I suppose this is the the reasoning
behind that decision and maybe better
saying something you said if white just
says okay I'll leave f6 on tap for a
moment and I play rook d7 maybe in that
case you can kind of demonstrate you
know that the rook on g6 might be a
little bit stuck and I'm Peter for our
audience so like rook d7 here rook e8
and what you're trying to do is chase
the rook on b7 away as you were
mentioning and exploit the work on g6
yeah this is this is a little bit tricky
even though even that position I suspect
there should be some kind of a solution
for white but does not feel does not
feel ideal for sure exactly and then the
alternative Bishop f6 well would yeah
this is this is what Magnus played he
took on a six black blade rookie six and
now I mean probably the the most obvious
way to not lose material here would be
come with the movie four which is what
he ends up playing before and I think
black needs to take on f6 and play this
rock n game but it's just such a poor
endgame ooh if I could even suggest put
the pawn a g6 in that variation Peter
oof that the pawn on g6 makes such a
even more pleasing impression so yeah
look at 6ef maybe that's even stronger
no it does allow Luke f7 I don't know
maybe it is the fact that there is rook
f7 shifts you're yeah this is your
opinion a little bit I don't yeah that's
that that's a pity I was hoping for a
rookie 6 ft 6 obviously when that pawn
creates a mating entanglement that yes
no no no in that case you're absolutely
right rook that's it and Phi B if I
because rook takes c4 I guess with the
intention of hasta Bishop takes you
seven playing room g4 either immediately
or perhaps you include the
first to drive the king further away
from okay from the the the black pieces
but this is also really not not great at
all
first impressions Peter is there's a
tremendous below rook g5 tickling the
rook at once as they say the night yeah
the night we want to blast the night
away yeah that that I missed and that
does seem does seem like maybe a cleaner
solution even because the night clearly
cannot go anywhere from a five and here
the rook g4 rook air-five
yeah that that endgame is horrible to
look at
even rugby 7 probably is the cleanest in
keeping both bones under attack and yeah
black blacks position will will just
collapse here again
Fabiano is in a situation in this
quarterfinals where he absolutely has to
be the victor in today's set of games
else he will lose the match Magnus will
be our semi-finalists rookie for and
here's Magnus thinking about Bishop e7
thinking about rook g5 it all looks good
how did neppo handle this oops yeah he
has he really had to go for it so we we
cannot really blame him for for going
for this position he included it might
be five first which i think is a
sensible enough idea at least forcing
black to play Knight a6 because
otherwise the other might will support
the my thumb he shakes but my cheeks is
quite clever here he booked with the e6
Knight took on a eight our team have
spent some time here trying to figure
out if he can somehow pick up the pawn
on e4 first and then go after the night
what came to the conclusion that that
doesn't quite work to Coney eight young
played b3 there will be some technical
issues here because I think hands next
to moves are probably f3 and Bishop a3
in some order I don't entirely know
which order but I have to congratulate a
yawn and finding a way of at least
making it awkward for his opponent yes
definitely is it definitely is a lot
more than I originally anticipated this
is a good sequence by yawn in particular
because that night on a6 is looking
rather rather silly
still worse but there's definitely
there's definitely a game going on at
the very least here which wasn't
necessarily the case here I think I've
always had this as a issue because if
you if you ever play a lot of chats
you're going to get into those positions
where you have two minor pieces for the
rook and I've always had that there's a
kind of an awkward issue maybe it's just
this specific position theater what's a
general rule of thumb when you have the
two pieces are you looking to trade
Queens or keep them on in other words in
that exact position should Queen e2 or
Queen before be considered or when you
hold the minor pieces I think it very
much depends on the structure and I
think with the pawn on d6 being as weak
as it is black probably wants the
Queen's on the board to have more
tactical ways of not dealing with
potential issues which will come up did
you ever create a principle no no I
think I think it's only on a
case-by-case basis for me I I don't
quite know how to sort of codify this
but I probably would have done would
have done as Ladislav Castagna and kept
the Queen's on Bishop e6 on the board
let's just check in with Magnus is he
putting the finishing touches on a game
that we're thinking is terrible
for fatty yeah as long as he doesn't
blend the rookie one mate I think he's
fine and I think it's very difficult to
blend a rookie one mate in this position
because black has just played rukka 88
so he is he is telegraphing the
intention to play to play rook e1 rather
rather strongly here so I think both
both f3 and g3 look look mighty
attractive here exactly
well I mean to my mind you know being
the materialist I am move like g2 g3 you
know which by the way does attack of
rook it's tax at night this amazing
threats that Fabio's facing isn't that
just a clincher Peter
well it looks horrible I think black has
to play rogue g4 here simply because
there's nothing else rook at 5 GF and
the other this position is just bad
there's no real way to describe it the
one kind of a semi saving grace for
black here is that he wants to play room
g7 so we cannot really take on h5 and
then pick up on b7 at leisure because of
Ruby g7 so we probably end up taking on
b7 and then black plays h4 and at least
some semblance of counter play appears
on the board but should not be enough
well having said that how about in that
case the move oh sorry I'd like board g3
I was about to suggest f3 the
alternative also this is why this is why
I thought that 3 was quite clever but g3
shouldn't really spoil anything either I
don't think I don't think it's a large
issue okay and well these are you may be
treated to decisive games here yeah and
in the in the second one myself actually
went for a conversion of one advantage
into the other after c4 in this position
he went Knight c5 Ruby won a six-night
c3 and just chose to trade in his two
pieces that he had for the rook for you
know the large part of the white
structure here by taking em b3 taking on
c4 yun played Queen B - and yun actually
preserves
I think decent drawing chances because
his structure remains very solid and
as long as his pieces don't get shifted
to really unfortunate squares here even
n games I think hold reasonable
reasonable drawing chances here for
white because of how how solid his
structure is having said that something
like Bishop d8 b6 whoops arrows again
Bishop d8 b6 might become might become a
reasonably big problem here for white
well my first impression the Peter I
can't shake it is that maybe vladislav
cashed in his chips a little early with
that 93 Bishop c4 I agree yeah it's a
it's an interesting it's an interesting
choice not not an obvious one let's put
it like this I think I think he
definitely could have could have maybe
waited for a bit but he is of course
still better he does oh he has an extra
pawn and also I thought Queen c5 check
was very clever by vladislav they're
making sure that white absolutely has to
play rook f2 due to the fact the king
each one takes F 1 will be would be an
oopsie
and now after work F 2 takes takes
recede rook c8 Bishop g2 and I guess now
we play Bishop d8 I think that like John
does have positional compensation but he
might not get to use it because he might
just never be able to deal with the very
very active pieces that black has the
Meade I don't know if that's actually
work on me yeah and you're right I mean
the black screen and c5
rook c8 the knight on f6 is ready jump
that Bishop to d8 b6
it looks like planting compensation to
me yeah Bishop did I think maybe the
only move even even is 91 to have Bishop
e3 available to us as a reply to Bishop
d6 but yeah even let's say the endgame
of the Queen c2 I think white is obliged
to take and then the pollen I do mind
just get picked up in in the near future
because you still have to
here above Bishop e6 I guess Bishop III
and yeah doesn't doesn't necessarily
look all that all that great for white
bishop d8 on the board meanwhile and as
mentioned I think apart from ninety one
white doesn't really even have any any
half sensible choices everything else
appears to be more or less losing on the
sport as far as I can tell very good I
cast my eye over to at the game of
Fabiano and I saw that he made this move
rook a8 nice it was like kind of like
recoiled in horror and rook ending if
you have to make your quick look in such
a defensive position things are really
bad things are really bad things are
things are really not going from bad to
worse here for for Fabi and let's say if
we have the same position but the black
king is on e6
I suspect it's still probably lost right
but I'm a lot less sure about that but
with the King also being cut off on the
back rank here I think there is almost
no hope whatsoever because even even
they absolutely straight forward winning
plans off I don't know pushing the phone
all the way up to b7 might might be
winning in some positions exactly with
the king cut off on the eighth-ranked or
Peter saying there's just even if you
give black everything you watch it which
upon a b6 and the rook magic black robe
magically appears behind the veep on it
may just be gone with the king not
actively placed on e6 I think that says
about a straightforward a book win as
you can get for Magnus just going with
the program and pushing his beep on the
board Peter yeah the question is let's
say we imagine and in the meantime all
of it all of this has already been
played but say after b6 they go Ruby 5
and you still need to form you like well
but I guess a5 King h5 King g6 will win
in some fashion right that probably is
what ends up happening why diverts the
black pieces towards the B file and then
picks up the pawn on f6 for the ponen b6
and wins that one quite
you know I guess this is extremely
likely to be the final outcome here
right and we just have seen Magnus
played not b6 he just played to move f5
leaving not allowing the work to
immediately get behind the pond f5 on
the board by Magnus and King f8 so that
you know like extra little improvement
certainly helps Maggie Magnus's position
yeah and in particularly here you played
b6 there's no way
Fabiana can afford to allow rooks e7 and
b7 that will just win on the spot right
therefore you have to play rugby Fife
and I suspect in this position King h5
Ruka v king g6 just ends the game pretty
much because once again rooks e7 and b7
will just be made if you allow that and
if you go back to be fine white picks up
the phone on the cheeks and then this is
about as easy a technical win as you can
find in in chess I think so this is
really really nasty because I just saw
f2 f3 on the board too so that when you
do go that ki Maya versus this is really
putting putting the nail in and you know
Magnus is poetry when he is on his game
and he is playing you know so very very
well it's just it's it's impressive
Peter I mean it is yeah it is it's uh
it's nice to watch him in full flight
admittedly I really feel like Fabi
probably did not play that game as well
as he normally would have but you still
have to you still have to beat him and
as someone who has played a decent
amount of chess against Navi I want to
attest that how difficult it is to win a
game of chess against him he is a very
very tenacious defender
it's a and Magnus made this look very
very easy
it wasn't Bishop versus
it wasn't yeah ending and let's turn to
the other game as I do want to say that
we have a learning moment coming up but
what happened in the Napo what's
happening
Peter I'm not entirely sure because
after 91 at the movie 65 which is what
Vladislav ended up going with it
occurred to me but I specifically I
couldn't really work out what's
happening after Queen takes b7 and this
is what young played Bishop d6 now by
our team EF and now we can go [ __ ] b3
let's say d4 and Bishop somewhere I
don't know g5 and maybe there's a
tactical solution but I don't see it yet
but I guess black maybe doesn't even
need a tactical solution because his
position is so nice but yeah I'm I'm not
a hundred percent certain what we're
supposed to think about this giving back
the call maybe maybe there is a force
solution but at the moment I'm missing
it d d3 bishop will retreat back to III
I think we go back and I was trying to
calculate some kind of romantic ideas
like this but I don't see a final blow
off the microphone well the nice part is
maybe you're onto it right here Peter we
do have a forget that night g8 will
defend checkmate
oh but d2 Queen takes beats I think
takes b6 we're simply a pawn up because
there's no mate right so yes that the
pawn does get to be the queen but we've
we've completely ruined our position in
the meantime so I I don't know how how
great that is
but this is one of those books that
belong in the combination the bloomerang
the book of combinations so instead of
having a combination book where every
tactic wins we have the opposite type of
book Peter where every tactic boomerangs
this is a Boomer
into IDIA it's a it's curious and Yun
starts by playing a 5-2 which our team
is very quickly goes Bishop a7
we should mention the clocks the clocks
are now three against two so both of
them despite this beam of 30 are still
in a I think four four players of their
pedigree in in online and blitz chess in
general they're still reasonably
comfortable I think on this or on this
time it's really not not panic panic
stations time yet and yes Yun does end
up playing Bishop III g4 and Bishop g5
has expected but with the inclusion of a
five display seven which I quite like
because the bishop is sort of clearly
slightly less well positioned on on that
Square and I always think in terms of
what our pieces are doing is wealthier
and for me the bishop on b6 whether it's
important or not does stop queen bee one
I don't know Queen d3 Queen d2 retreats
so the inclusion of a5 was in my view
like yours very clever I like that
inclusion lot yeah I think I think I
think it's clearly clearly a good thing
and black now needs to need to show
exactly what he means here is it right
yes this is the moment
Vladislav was a Pathan before he seemed
to be nursing
upon and very good pieces he returned
the pawn to get his deep on to the d4
square and now he need follow-up began
Vladislav the number one seed from the
polina's is in a position he needs to
win today said we've just seen rook b8
peter Yarrow pietà i think is very
logical and also this you know you could
say that this is the one difference
between a 5x7
and no a5 Bishop a7 which is in blacks
favor because now this rook is very
squarely aimed at the b1 r square where
it will generate a tone of
very very dangerous threats no honestly
I'm I'm not even sure how we're supposed
to if we deal with this Queen takes a
six you know me Peter when a six rugby
one we David 323i Miss Queen d3 do I
need to include d3 earlier it's kind of
a strange one because there's also no d3
earliest probably doesn't work so Queen
d3 ah how is this position I don't know
I don't know Queen d2 or Queen e1 I
don't know which one you prefer honestly
I'll go with the one you chose
hanging in there hanging in there it's
still don't I still don't I'm not
feeling it Peter yeah the knight on f6
is just so cut off from from all the
action that's what that's the piece that
black kind of is lacking in in his in
his attack if you could somehow get this
Knight to participate but it's
completely restricted by the these two
pawns clinics played here I think there
was probably probably no other choice
frankly so well not really surprising
that this is what Ruby look frightening
yeah and you just need to bring the
Queen back into the defense something
like Queen f7 looks attractive for for a
second and then you realize you are not
the one the one giving mate here you are
the one being mated on the other side of
the board and right there's just no time
to play Bishop f6 because black quite
simply goes d43 discovered check and
then picks the rook up with maid so in
a6 and now yeah now black will need to
demonstrate what he what he has Ruby one
played I assume Queen D 3 will be
blitzed out because any other square you
will just lose the g43
on the spot you cannot afford to allow
black not to open that Bishop on a7 for
free sing on a second is this whoa no
doesn't work I was good I was getting
very excited about this move Wow but it
doesn't work because Queen takes be one
Queen e1 chair crew
one g3 discovered check and then the
rook actually protects the Queen on 1v1
and black ends up not giving any kind of
mate mm-hmm otherwise Queen c3 would be
a very nice geometrical geometrical
trick which well he played rook F 1
interesting I did not think this was
possible but maybe it is I guess the
point is after d3 check King H 1 Queen F
2 white steel has been takes d3 trying I
keep on trying to have to give some very
beautiful maids but there are just no
mate so obviously has some beautiful
geometry there I just wanted to say that
you you can't
after d3 check play the move Bishop e3
because black is very happy to give up
this Queen for all your pieces and your
king oops
absolutely yeah so things are really
getting out of hand a bit here for
vladislav what's going on and the
current position many I I really don't
know I think black probably is still
fine but after g3 Young will just take
on d3 allow Queen g1 check and go to e2
and it is now black who has back rank
issues mm-hmm
which means that there is no obvious way
to let's say if the Queen takes your
cooking King I don't know g1 or even
even maybe g1 and then run towards
towards the Queen side I'm beginning to
like white in this position honestly
exactly there is an a5 on still on the
board so we do have tea for d3 up 33 all
of this has been I guess he Ana's trying
to figure out if Bishop e3 just wins on
the sport which it might oh there's a
background may threat on Queen see a
catcher yeah that would be that would be
a very very bitter bitter pill to
swallow for vladislav because I think
he's been driving the action I think he
can still play Queen c2 though maybe
maybe everything is not are lost as such
because at the Queen C do we create a
threat of Queen B 1 which is
a very strong and this is I guess why
young hasn't played this yet case like
g4 or something yeah yeah maybe yeah g4
but not afore I guess yeah oh oh and you
might he played Bishop III and Queen c3
replied by party I think he is planning
to give up this piece now I think this
might be his intention just take stakes
and now play a six and go for ninety
five ninety six and a seven I have a
feeling this is what he is going for
here
that might just be winning Peter he
played g3 not g4 but g3 which is a lot
smarter obviously or 683 what what what
what keeping the checkmates alive
there's no this actually happened there
was no choice maybe I guess g3 was just
winning maybe but that would imply that
maybe Queen c2 was stronger or possibly
g3 was winning anyway because after
Queen e2 King g2 you still have no
defense against Queen c8 mate
yeah very dramatic conclusion to that
game which really felt like what is love
was in in control of for here at Peter
as we do have Magnus Carlsen and Napo
taking a one-and-a-half to a half point
lead in fact it's their opponents who
needed to win to stay in the match and
oh my goodness it looks like another
game has already started I actually
wanted to take us to a learning moment I
think we can still do that because that
opening they will level seemingly
they're playing a very theoretically
heavy f3 NIMS oh and we can talk about
the theory of that line later if there
is a if there's a learning moment to to
talk about here let's learn something
yeah I promise to be very brief here
since we all want to catch up with the
action in this game 3 between Karen and
Carson but I do want to choose the
learning moment of the previous round
between these two after move 19 in the
game Carlson Caruana I thought rooks t7
well we all know the rules
the rook always wants to go to the
seventh or second rank depending on from
which perspective you are looking at the
board rooks are extremely powerful on
the seventh rank and this move is
particularly strong saying some
now the knight and upon are hanging the
only way to try to escape from this
situation is Knight to f5 which attacks
the rook on d4 and I want to highlight
here that it's very tempting after
Knight to f5 to go pawn grabbing by
taking on the 8-bit check and then
taking the pawn on b7 but this trade on
d8 is actually not advisable since it
activates black's rook and now look to
d2 the same motive rooks on the second
or seventh rank are very powerful and
black has enough counter play to make it
through this endgame so the winning move
was that Magnus Carlsen played rook to
g4 after which they are away to many
threats so instead of taking on the aid
instead of trading the rooks now rook to
d4 threatening Bishop takes f6
threatening a4 and the pawn on b7 is
still hanging
Fabiano tried with h5 but then the
precise move is rook to g6 so many pins
are there on this board that for
instance if King to h7 white can simply
take the pawn on f6 with the rook
so King has seven steps into rook takes
f6 and if instead what happened in the
game rook e8 the poem was taken on f6
with the bishop and the final tactical
motive so instead of king gage 7 we had
rookie eight in the game bishop takes f6
if we show that moment real quick as
well and now this final tactical motive
that Magnus of course so was that if
Ruki 6 which happen in the game this
pins the bishop so it does look like
white would lose the piece doesn't it
now there's a very strong and only move
here for white efore which attacks the
knight so in case black takes on f6 we
will also take the knight on f5 and the
knight cannot jump away because the g7
point is hanging this was the way in
which Magnus Carlsen took a winning
advantage in his game against Fabiano
and now we shall see whether Khurana can
make it
back in Game three thank you very much I
know that was a very very nice game
indeed by Magnus I just want to take a
moment here to tell you that Grand
Master Erwin me will very very shortly
be joining us or when one of Holland's
very strongest Graham masters is also
noted for being a great coach as he
works with onigiri he has done a
chasuble course and he's gonna tell us
all about it when he joins us in the
meanwhile um Peter back to you what has
happened in this heavyweight there a
tackle discussion that Fabian that yeah
it's it's it's a it's a well a line of
the f3 names are which i think is not
currently are the the most topical one I
think there are other ways of treating
there are three names of which have
superseded this but it's it's what used
to be I think the absolute central line
of the opening g-53 Bishop takes c3 B c3
n c5 this used to be very very central
in the theory of the bf3 neum so I can
name a few players in my mind and I
understand it will sound a little bit
silly the f3 names oh and in particular
this line well I guess forever be
associated with the Russian Grand Master
who is not that famous I think in the
West Sergei Volkov who I think played
the f3 nimza for the in the the entirety
of his 30 plus year career no really not
not straying very far away from that
opening at any point which is you know a
very admirable faith being shown to to
the one line C d5 Knight takes d5 d c5
is the absolute main line here Queen a5
seemingly the pawn on c3
is is hanging with with check and I mean
I use seemingly here slightly ironically
it is hanging with check but white says
do go on please please take it if you
wish and and plays e4 and it turns out
that Queen takes c3 of
versus ill-advised because of Bishop d2
and then the knife will fall and if you
take on c3 with the Nightwind d2
followed by Bishop b2 is very very good
now and then there is a huge discussion
on whether this Knight is supposed to go
I think all the moves that don't lose
the knight and miss position have been
quite seriously discussed and and played
in Grandmaster practice night of 697
yeah arrows neither 697 n night c7 even
but neither 6 I think is probably the
main one Bishop e3 once again black
doesn't take on city 3 here because it
just gives up
Tempe that white needs to bring his
pieces into the game black ghost castles
a4 on Knight 67 and king f2 generally
this is where this King belongs in this
line why doesn't even attempt to Castle
very often because of how comfortable
this game is in this little a little
hidey hole on on f2 but perhaps Irvine
can tell us something about the theory
of this line because I think I'm out I
don't really know anything else I'm I've
exhausted my my very very limited
knowledge well I know our one have you
joined us don't hear a confirmation yet
from Irwin I think I do want to remind
our viewers that to every guest we have
on the show you can also ask them
questions if you use the hashtag study
chess so take advantage of this moment
if you want to ask a question to
Grandmaster Aaron Loup me long time
second of an expiry and the author of
multiple courses and books do let us
know on twitter by using the hashtag
study chess what would be your question
to Aaron thank you for the heads of yes
sir absolutely and there he is yeah and
some handsome as ever
hey someone the ghost and welcome to the
show Aaron thank you great to be here
not a sermon where are you by the way if
I can ask I am in the most beautiful
city of the Netherlands wooden clothes
to attract for people unfamiliar with
water
most beautiful city yes already
contentious nice to have you words yeah
not yet Zack we Peter nice to have a
have you with us
Erwin you've been watching the action uh
nation's been playing very very well
back this way to victory I'm sure you
enjoyed watching that it's looking well
your overall take of the chest bull
masters well it's been great I think I
really like the format so I've been
enjoying the qualification stage a lot
and especially well today and of course
the first measure with this mention
think awesome in Carolina they're always
fantastic it I was of course after the
clutch image that they had I was
expecting a little bit more of a close
it looks like Carlson is it's really
donating so far but I always like to see
these two head to head so it's been very
exciting for me so far to watch they
agree the preliminaries usually we're
just at the edge of our seats
exactly and and well now we're in the
knockout match things so lots to look
forward to
Erwin you've come at a very good moment
because in the game between Fabio and
Magnus the exact position that they have
on the board both Peter and I you know
we're tapped out on our theoretical
knowledge we wanted to bring in and open
the there with issues like yourself okay
the pressures on my coming guide is
through the byways and the pathways that
were currently facing what's going on
well I'm afraid to have very bad news
i watch sure I can tell you much I
honestly
perhaps I've hooked this position once
or twice but the problem for me is that
when I haven't seen a position for a
couple of weeks it's usually just
totally gone so I just yeah maybe I see
Peter noting I don't know it's very much
the same for most people these days and
it's exactly like that yeah exactly so I
I may have
seeing his position before but it
doesn't ring ring and ring a bell to
Mills I I do like that for black it's
pretty obvious then what the next few
moves are I mean I guess Bishop a6 will
come get the knight on b8 out rooks
rooks to d8 CAS and that's pretty
obvious so I think wife has to really
show something here that's I guess a
pleasant thing to be and to be having
with Britt black yeah I agree I agree
with all of that I think strategically
blacks play is just simpler here you do
one Bishop a6 you want to connect the
ropes somehow in particular of course if
I takes on a6 but even if he doesn't you
can develop this Knight over to d7 Ruby
g8 rook c8 there is this complex of
potential weaknesses on on the Queen
side and generally blacks position
contains no weaknesses whatsoever right
now so there's really not not very much
to worry about apart from maybe some
potential tactical issues with the Queen
on a5 which are somewhat highlighted by
the move Bishop b5 if we imagine why
playing c4 and Bishop d2 that Queen
might be gone but of course Magnus will
have something to say about it
I think we should be v is mainly aimed
at trying to provoke a6 which will take
away that Square from from the bishop at
least making it slightly more difficult
for black to develop and this is
actually the way he would like to yeah
this is a moment I really wanted to jump
in and say there is a trick here there's
night e to saying maybe that's so that's
actually very clever I didn't see that
yeah maybe you're like maybe find off a
little bit no I don't know
vulnerable there we have it I like this
I like this quite a bit yeah yes but but
honestly I just don't like a sig so
sadly for us I don't expect this this
nifty little trick to to actually appear
on the board I would like to continue
with my with my Bishop h6 play if I'm
able but I guess white is intending to
take and take maybe them and say that
now I can sort of see how I can be
better in the future because I have more
pawns and if you try to win that pawn
back straight away maybe I can go 92
here and 97 instead of fire I'm sorry I
missed 97 year of course yeah sorry I
just blanked on the fact that this move
is possible I guess we go Queen before
but that probably ends up being some
kind of a draw right
yeah just taking on before on b5 fake on
before take on b5 go rook FBA this
always and like mass mass
simplifications and a draw pretty much
pretty much in every in every single
case so yeah I think Bishop a6 is the
most topical move here perhaps white can
find something there but this is where
we should be looking maybe white can go
Bishop c5 be c5 and just develop a knife
here in white black to take on b5 a be
your queen takes b5 through cage b1 but
here as well like why should black be so
unhappy is my question
oh maybe you can take on c5 after Bishop
takes b5 I am this is the position I
wanted actually version of oh yeah this
is exactly the position I wanted yeah
that makes sense that makes sense this
is not immediate equality for sure
erwin first of all i want to say
congratulations on your chest core
secondly i also wanted say
congratulations on your answer to the
question of the day and you have won
your own copy of your own chess goal oh
thank you
well done for both things but i always
like to ask the chests authors because i
like to say about myself
that no matter how badly i teach i
always learn something what is it about
your chess course on the dubov Tarrasch
that you learned yourself that surprised
you
well first of all this line it has
existed since well more than hundred
years already but but it used to be
considered not not playable so the mere
fact that do both took it on and
actually made the whole line playable
that was already a huge thing
yeah well Peters shown me moves already
this line used to just consider
considered to be pretty bad for for
Blackie Bishop c5 etc can take on c6 893
is a move there are many moves here too
much to go into right now obviously but
it was just considered there tonight
b3 in this in this position that black
would go for instance Bishop before if
we can briefly show that on the other
word and figured after Bishop before
Castle that black would have to take on
on c3 in that in that position and give
up the D pair of bishops and that's of
course a little bit of a lousy position
but do both show that have to move
Knight Basilica nation just go Bishop e6
sacrifice that pawned on on on d5 and
that actually turned out to be
completely fine so that entire concept
actually is entirely new and one of the
many things actually do both recently
brought to the game because he's I think
been one of the most inspiring players
when it comes to opening ideas in this
era yeah absolutely that last statement
is something I've said countless times
on there I think he is very much you
know a major driving force moving moving
the game forward in terms of finding
finding interesting new ideas and
exactly it's a bit I mean the game
against obtaining if I think it was it
comes to mind from for the previous from
from the qualification I mean so many
interesting ideas and yeah it's just
remarkable actually because we're all
working on the game but somehow he's the
one coming up with all the all the fun
ideas absolutely yeah there was a great
crying and the cosmic force when Donald
crashed down at the prelim yeah yeah
yeah I agree with ya the cosmic force
yeah yeah because for me the game that
he defeated
Magnus with that rook b2 in Queen c2
yeah it was really a work of art so I
mean it was said that you know some yeah
they had to make room for our
quarter-finalists our win now let's talk
a little bit about your boy yeah
Amish seems to be in as usual in
fighting trim where the social media is
concerned but he's also been playing
really well of late your take I think
that given his previous results in the
contest to reputable aides which weren't
always great I think at some point he
took a conscious decision to focus on
rapid blitz and then of course Corona
struck and and basically everything
became the templates online events and
he really took that very serious I think
it's been now starting to show in his
results I mean he had this match with
with Magnus of course in the in the in
the first leg of the tour which was a
great result for him but now he's been
yeah it's actually he starts he starts
fighting for the prices now so I'm very
happy to see that obviously obviously
back to the game pier the players
following our analysis they're here very
much so but instead of [ __ ] basics he
played Bishop d7 which i think is played
with the intention of having rook c8 as
an option available to him you still
need to have the answer to 92 though I'm
not entirely sure what the plan the plan
here is we'll need to figure that out
Queen b6 yeah maybe maybe just Queen b6
but I mean how happy are we with this
endgame is is my question here this ship
takes d5 just follow that Peter you want
to take on Bishop e5 yeah I don't know
maybe takes takes and takes and hmm we
have a list of in the other matches well
one b3 Arian your thoughts on this
opening choice by Artemyev I want some
fantasy points I'm very happy I was just
thinking it was in the fantasy contest
and I think
said there will be no 1v3 I'm so
regretting it well actually I just I
mean speaking of Artemia I just finished
today recording my next accessible
course on the CARICOM and I saw at Amy
I've also played efore c6 g3 once so in
that sense I think b3 is a completely
normal way of of starting the game I
don't know I think jokes aside I tell me
if he generally doesn't aim to decide
games in the opening so for him it's
just I think he's more than happy to
just get get a game and start playing
he's one of though it's quite rare I
think these days it's one of those
players that that really doesn't seem to
be all that bothered by a deep opening
prep it almost seems like a combination
of Donnell and wladislaw together he
would be very formidable the way we
describe Peter I take is from the star 1
d3 how did the players get here it'd be
three if I wish to be to night of 96
this is sort of the old mainline and
there should be five Bishop d6 in
particular is is very much how they used
to play this opening in the times of
your and I'm using you know the times of
your here thank you very very liberally
maybe 20 years ago is is what we're
referring to here yeah but yeah that
that used to be very very topical night
a 395 HP to a6 somewhat surprisingly all
of this has been sort of well researched
at some point weird as all these moves
might look to to our viewers
now c4 I don't believe I have seen c7 c5
in this position I would have thought
just returning with a night but she
seeks Gosling playing rook e8 and so on
would be quite normal but c5 is is a way
to fight over for the center which is
also quite logical 92 96 and here
because of the fact that night of 3 is
met quite well by 5 before
Vladislav goes for the immediate d4
which is a very sharp attempt to to
fight for advantage
which is connected with having to play
king of one but I'm pretty sure he is
not really that unhappy about it this is
the position we have on the board right
now and he played witcher 3 if you
imagine white already let's say the
knight on G 1 is on g3 and White Castle
why do I think is close to winning so so
you can you can definitely see why why
Vladislav would like this because from a
purely strategic point of view I think I
think that there is a lot to be happy
about here with white the question is of
course where the black can develop
something significant
in the center here now before actually
wide gets out of the corner before white
let's say goes 90 to 94 g3 and King g2
after which I think it might be already
a little bit too late when I see or when
shaking his head vigorously though he
agree it I mean position with huge
potential
I see nip or just best out d5 which I
think I think at least that that tries
to stir things up a little bit me such
things I think has been did you say
think I think the 555 is extremely
logical yes very much like a white like
this move as well yeah I think I think
this was required yes pretty much
and 55 what would be the the
continuation oh yeah I don't know Bishop
d6 Bishop d7 something like that - yeah
yeah by the way I was trying to be
humorous there the I judge my audience
by the amount of laughter I received
when I said that you were shaking your
head vigorously I was being untruthful
Huracan how do you see the position Yan
Yan has now sacrificed upon after Bishop
takes d5 full compensation no I agree
with everything that that Peter said of
course I mean if Y could have gotten a
few moves in that position like 92 94 g3
kingi to roopd 1 but black and just
resigned probably so
d5 was a must
and yeah maybe he has enough play but I
would definitely take the quite okay I'm
like you in any way I like grabbing this
must be the day of funky King moves
since we have King f1 in our champions
game current Ice King was on f2 and
right now an f3 can be update the
viewers on the position yeah it's it's
curious because we left it somewhere
here and Magnus played in 97 Queen takes
b5 Queen c7 this is a kind of a typical
typical position where black is
seemingly a healthy pawn down but the
night only 2 is much worse then the
night which is likely to be only 5 next
move you often see compensations like
this in in green fields even there are
Lions where in particularly if the black
bone was on b6 and not only 7 opening up
the a rook as well to have come to play
against the a4 pond those positions are
generally just considered to be not
better at all for white but as things
stood after 95 I be instantly drove that
night are away from that excellent
square Knight c-47 is quite awkward for
black because you either have to play a
very awkward move Queen c8 or you have
to offer a queen trade on b6 which is
not that great when you're born down
Magnus preferred to play 94 check and
then Knight of 6 and if I played a very
cute move Queen e5 which if black in the
position after the Queen trade had the
move 97 available would obviously be a
horrible mistake because you don't
really want to be doing this to your
structure but because the only square
that I can actually go to is ei tier and
after only 7 it probably doesn't move
again in this game Queen takes e5 wasn't
really a playable option for Magnus he
instead played Queen e7 and Ruby for
Lucchesi a true b1 followed white is a
pawn up here and I think Magnus will
have to play very very well too
to defend this position he still has
some compensation but white stabilized
to a very large degree I've totally
agree with you Peter and in fact when I
look at this rook on d4 I see it as
really very powerful it defends
weaknesses across the fourth ring that
it also controls so many squares uh well
I mean as we know fati needs to win the
day and of course he is trailing in the
match by a game so now I never kind of
situation going on here
or when jumping in here your take on
this position I mean it still feels like
there is some compensation because the
king is on f3 but the King on f3 would
only be weak if it was vulnerable is it
well I don't really see a clear
continuation in 97 we go Queen d6
probably we just exchanged the Queen's I
don't see a clear way forward here why
it is not completely stable yet to the
King on f3 always I guess have some
composition White has some weaknesses
c3a for but yeah I'm I'm not sure what
maybe just Riku p8 just just make a
party so to speak we sing rock d8 there
was a trade of rooks and it's already on
the door ports it takes takes 24 and 27
all of this has been played ok yeah
because because the whites King site has
been slightly opened it's not it's not a
given that you convert this but it's up
it's a pleasant it's a pleasant position
for 5b to play for instance you can I
think you can move the pawn from c3 to
c5 here but it might get lost there
I think after you five black would like
to play 95 and you can play C 4 using
the fact that the back rank is weak but
honestly I don't like after 97 n96 I
think we've probably created issues for
ourselves more than anything else so
unsurprisingly Fabi decides against it
and just in more general terms I think
playing e5 unless it wins you something
is not not in fabi's plans right now
because the knight on f6 is quite
passive and giving it good squares would
be very counterproductive so Ruby even
cuts off the night once again from the
g7 square and after h6 Bobby goes h4g
for which is quite a striking quite a
striking choice
yeah nice some action or when we have a
question for you from our social media
as Ana's been monitoring all of our
channels and you've got a big fan base
you do have a big fan base so I decided
I would choose the tweet of your biggest
fan boy and his Geary tweeting to try
and weather the storm
I am sending my best and most diplomatic
representative Arian love me right into
the lion's den
chest that chest 24 broadcast he soon
publishing his character and chasuble
course to which is perhaps the second
best opening against 1.e4 hashtag study
chest
Earvin your thoughts on the Twitter
banter friendly war between Aneesh and
Magnus first of all I think I'm just
very happy that Aisha always promotes my
adjustable courses so that I don't have
to do anything any promotion by myself
basically I'm very happy with that yeah
it's his fee I have a course coming out
so I need to he's been remarkably
friendly about Buffy so I'm sure that
can be discussed but the question was
about the banter between Carson and
unassuming or indeed it does seem like
they are having a small Twitter war
again how do you see the social media
interaction is this friendly banter does
he ask for advice from his second on
what or from his side no I'm afraid I'm
not a social media a second I tend to
stick more to opening variations and
stuff like that no but I think it's all
it's all fun I think they're both
enjoying there to poke at each other and
I think generally it's it's only been
being fun we are most certainly enjoying
their benefit and also the chess about
blocks I think a niche has chosen every
single possible moment for saying that
one e6 is the best response to e4 I'm
still way
thing for him to play it more often
though yeah that's that's the thing with
my course you can at least be sure they
also practice what I preached so well
CARICOM I I played it my entire life
actually sometimes it's my main
variation sometimes I just used it
occasionally but it's always been around
so what can I say I'm trying to to PR my
my car account here but I think that
it's just a very fun cause and I worked
for about three months it was of course
corona times so I had a lot of time to
to work on it and I'm actually kind of
proud of there's also I really hope that
it will be appreciated and there's all I
can say yeah I've got a question for you
on your car concours coming up because I
want to ask you how you use the 3700
engine to help you out in the meanwhile
before we get to that question or when
let's focus on this flank attack Peter G
4h for uh uh Abbey's agenda is it
serious I think it's a very clever idea
because one thing I think was lacking
here for white is is an active plan to
improve his position and the idea of
controlling everything on the G file and
then actively driving the action on the
kingside planning to go h4 and g5 and
drive the night further away from a
reasonably good square on the six where
at least it kind of keeps White's white
honest keeping an eye on e4 pawn and
preventing white from gaining more space
it's very very clever I think and Magnus
after some thought ends up playing rook
e8 here intending to go e65 next which
is also I think a very very decent
response very interesting sequence off
of goo moves here Wow that move rook e8
I think that would be move that the yarn
hind honor would call deep nice but then
again can we can we pretend we we don't
understand how deep it is and just go h4
and F takes e okay rook takes I guess
yeah my intention here is to say okay
now
we play my pawn up endgame and I guess
you go King h7 and I go Ruby 400k to pay
five-year rookie for ya and I understand
there are definitely drawing tendencies
here just some drawing tendencies but we
shouldn't be so unhappy about this with
white right no we get we get the sunny
side of the torture and I know or when
you you like the sunny side I love this
instead chosen by Fabiano Oh allowing
both Queen b7 and Quincy for two which I
assume the reply is Ruby for in both
cases or yes exactly but hang on a
second if I play Queen b7 here and you
go Ruby for don't have Quinn be one
Queen each one he's played Queen C for
instead can actually get more Peter
after after Luke d4 go a 5/5 roads ah
that that also was huh we couldn't be 7
Queen before was intended but that feels
counterintuitive yeah that's a very
important tactic there in 1944 a5 which
I completely miss major and alert but
Quincy for was chosen instead and what's
the reply of the rock before does he
intend to go to a two or maybe Cooney to
yeah but that doesn't create a single
maybe Knight takes d4 yeah so after g5
we could maybe even go Knight g4
straightaway Rudy - Rudy - Knight h2
King G - though yeah we we win the night
I don't know it's maybe maybe 94 wasn't
even a threat because you have to so I
guess we just go take stakes in Knight
h7 and claim that the night might get
rerouted by a good squares and somewhat
surprisingly Fabi says no to all of that
as well so that I think is a very good
indication that Queen before was coming
after Queen b7 as well he goes green
before here but what's the move after I
don't know this feels like we were miss
playing our pieces a little bit yeah
moment ago it felt like there was
greater course
even in a White's setup and something
maybe not going that great briefly if
you will earn because we've got such a
wonderful game on going how did the 3700
chess engines a I help you with your
chess well I I got that I got the
question what is the most overrated
piece of of advice and I think that for
a long time the advice not to use the
computer was perhaps a fill at one in
the 90s when you had only Fritz and
Fritz would point out some some some
obvious tactical errors but wouldn't
really show you any any any maneuvering
and he wouldn't show any knowledge of
structures etc and I just wanted to make
the point that I think if you use
engines these days in the right way so
in an active and engaging way where you
don't switch off your head and just look
at what the engine spits out but you
actually input your own moves and you
see what you get in response and and
sort of used as a sparring partner that
I think there's a lot to learn because
about the latest engines out there the
lillas and rockfish they are so
incredibly good and they they understand
chess to such a degree that I think we
would be crazy not to not to use it so I
think it's mostly an old advice which i
think is no longer apply applicable to
this to this date thank you for that
Peter and yeah I've been drawing I've
been drawing arrows like crazy here
because Yong Yong found maybe the most
beautiful move of the past couple of
days just now Wow
and is just so nice to look at this
position even from of like a static
perspective we left it somewhere around
here and after 92 rooky 8 black clearly
has lots of play but the way the Y
position collapsed I feel like our team
is probably miscalculated something he
played this / 3 before 5 Queen a 427 of
course black is not interested in
playing any end games here and vladislav
who perhaps was also running slightly
short on time
he chose to give up this dark square
bishop I don't know if not taking on a
six would have made a blind bit of
difference to be honest but he he chose
this which I thought was interesting
because let's say some of the bishops
III might pick up this rook on Avon but
white would be extremely happy to play
some kind of position like this
and in general white is maybe two moves
away from completely consolidating but
Bishop d1 is such a beautiful move by by
yon cutting the rook on a one from the
control over the e1 square so rook e1
with me is now a threat now if you take
of course this runs into queen d3 check
and you lose and stunningly you can't
even play Bishop e2 for instance because
after Queen g1 check you still get mated
in exactly the same way Bishop takes d1
rook e1 mate
it feels to me like this is just
completely lost our TV friends are
playing King G one night of one but
after Queen d3 for instance I think he
loses pretty much his entire his entire
chess set
I don't think you can defend the knight
on f1 here and and then the rook on h1
will also fall so I think the British
have a wonderful expression that move
Bishop b1 was very very visual visual
move Bishop d1 our move of the day for
sure what's happening how it escalated
so quickly because we thought white was
actually doing great right yeah we
thought somewhere like here I'm pretty
sure the computer can find the way in
this position to do not allow too many
threats to materialize it feels unclear
to me I don't know I don't know maybe we
were overstating the case quite a bit
here yeah interesting basically this is
this is move 15 and this is move 20 and
the game is pretty much over and not the
way we expected it to be over so a very
very dramatic turnaround and and there's
been a very big turnaround in the second
one as well where Magnus is no longer
fallen down and you know if it continues
like this he might start playing for a
win for all we know whoa whoa moment ago
we thought that Abby was about to get
his grippers on the position we saw move
rook e8
it's maybe a little bit disturbing but
this has gone way out of control I'm
looking at Queen h4 and I'm saying
Magnus is winning i mean i mean he's
threatening well i think i think winning
is a little bit too strong because i
think we can play it in c5 or Queen b6
and stop Queen have to check and then
the game still continues but here Magnus
is in control in particular say Queen b6
even the move like Knight f6 attacking
and then picking up the pawn on e4
probably just just wins and briefly our
teams did find a way not to resign on
the spot here by playing queen g4 check
and rookie and Bishop e2 but after rook
takes you to for instance room takes b1
hoping for Queen d1 we need to know you
can play Ruby g8 here you can play
Bishop c5 Bishop c5 probably the
cleanest one and yeah I think I think
why just resigns here because there's
just no way to defend against the
multiple multiple threats Black has by
the way just to boldly state the obvious
I think that that would be two and a
half points for yan should he win this
particular game that would give him the
asset and the match chance
yes thank you there you go set and match
and he would be our first quarter
finalists and I suspect not very far
behind is gonna be Magnus because I'm
telling you guys I'm not feeling into
here at all for fabbi also looking at
the chloride yeah 19 seconds against a
minute and 40 and the position is
genuinely very dangerous at the very
least h2 pawn can be picked up with
check and then black would just start
running his h-bond down the board so
yeah just a very very poor position here
for that looks like a very obvious
solution for Magnus win H to Jack that's
looking g3 I guess we run towards the
she poop on square and then we hope to
pick up on a5 and get to so Knight f6 to
stop Queen e8 perpetual check yeah and
now it's a race I guess it's a race that
black is favored in but
at least it's a race and indeed in the
meantime Artemyev resigned against
nippon-ichi it's a forced made the very
end of the game meaning that Nepal
machine moves on to the semi-finals
where his opponent will be either Alec
or your boy Aaron and his Giri
Erwin jump in yeah I think Annie showed
that he's very solid this hasn't lost a
single game actually so I'm confident
he's done well and should be nice to see
him paired against nip over soon
well by the way you mentioned that I win
and I really wanted to ask you about it
you said that uh nation's been working
on his blitz and his rapid chess skills
how do you do that playing online a lot
it's been pretty active on the various
websites so playing everything that
there is to play base basically he's
playing blitz matches with friends etc
so he's taking a conscious decision to
well I think it's Romo because a lot of
top events have gone through to faster
time control so so I think you have to
make an effort to yeah to do to improve
it was never his his specialty but it
would be nice of course if he could
simply add it to his repertoire of you
know and become an expert there as well
so I assume as a as a good second you
and a nation engage in the affair revel
and we recently did actually but it's
it's very painful because especially
when it's when it's online I used to
pride myself in being decent bit prior
online but he was I was just being
totally annihilated so I'm afraid he
already needs different opponents at
this point to do spar against he's
faster his trickier he's well better
it's very very painful actually so I'm
not sure I'm
I'm eager to play many more matches well
with him Peter is doing on the board
yeah I'm having I'm having fun there I
enjoy I enjoy listening I enjoy
listening to everything but it also
gives me it gives me an opportunity to
just have some fun on the demonstration
board and I mean the issue with my Devon
check is that King Siwon is is a move
you can play so I think 94 is a very
kind of a sane and sober decision there
by Magnus it's cleaner this way but it
was acute acute tactic Magic Kingdom on
the Queen defy forcing probably an
immediate resignation out of white but I
like 94 there's nothing wrong with 94 93
just established this night on the six
and then black has you know black has
two extra pawns and they are the two
outside passers as well the h and the a
so there's really not very much going
for for white here we might have a very
short day again amazingly we might both
of these quarter-finals might go like
the entire length of six games which is
which is very surprising very surprising
considering you know how generally close
in strength everybody is in this
tournament and I was preparing for a
long day you know and nice we've just
seen the move we e da check babbies
running out of time he's running out of
position he was down to five seconds
when he came up with Queen e7 and Magnus
instantly queen b5 keeping the pressure
on this looks terrible
everyone yeah I think it's just
completely lost and now for a three
probably is the cleanest solution just
start running one of your passers down
the board because Queen takes f7 is not
a threat with the Queen connected to the
925 and Queenie v a3 is also just
completely lost that bond will just win
the game for for Magnus so yeah this is
now on the board and even if I we didn't
have 14 seconds to go with it it
probably would be a dead lost position
for white but as it is it's both the
position
and in the time and he has resigned and
another incredibly accurate move they're
just at the very end I mean how you
don't play a to is amazing but I think
we need for is just even that more
accurate but fantastic play just I mean
Fabiano earlier early and I just want to
bring you up to date at the start of
play you know being objective in neutral
they asked me who was going to win the
chest Bowl masters and I said who would
the Americans playing yeah those guys
those guy abbey looks not like the
number two player in the world in this
magic incredible performance yeah that's
also I mean macness if he's in shape
then it's really hard to stop him and he
seems to be in great shape
actually this games also today we're
really good I mean that yeah nothing to
say yeah yeah I mean it what's crazy
though or will and Peter on a jump it is
at times you're not even sure he's
playing rabbit chest these look like
correspondence games or it's amazing is
that mercy is fantastic yeah the quality
the quality is stunning and today he
seemed to be very much on his game and a
couple of mistakes from favi was perhaps
all it took for for the match to be over
in three games well let's have the man
speak for himself Magnus Carlsen welcome
to the show Oh sounds like an audio
issue Magnus
everything is working now everything's
working okay congratulations Bravo well
done tell us how you did it yeah I gotta
say was a pretty good clean day today in
the first game obviously I got a
comfortable position I was somewhat
better but I don't think it was enough
to win at any point and then I was in
there in the second game
things went south pretty early for him
and I think after work before he's just
pretty much lost so um obviously that
was that was a very good start for me
this bad yeah there's just no way back
from here you know I think work did for
it's just so pretty much over like me
has to search for some fairly miniscule
chances where I think he loses upon
whatever whatever he does and in the
game I
I mean 97 9 to 5 it's kind of the most
logical defense but I think Ruchi 426
just wins and afterward out there there
wasn't that much to be said Oh apart
from I think I could have saved myself a
bunch of time at one point when I went
g3 if I just go Bishop c3 instead I
think that's a lot more accurate mmm I
the idea I didn't check it but I am I
was a little bit upset after I played g3
because then I saw Bishop c3 and that
should be should be plain sailing from
there yeah that does seem very clean him
yeah rook at Ford g3 Ruka through Quincy
- I don't think there's there's a lot
there um anyway the game was winning as
well um then obviously the the third
game was by far the the toughest and he
did find an interesting concept there
when I mean when he when he went for
this line with Quincy five Quinby d5 I
actually and I didn't I didn't believe
in that at all for him I just thought
with good development and better pieces
I should be doing well but I completely
underestimated the concert with with f4
and that actually made me made me suffer
a bit did you feel you were
actually significantly worse at any
point or was it just having to play
precisely to keep afloat oh yeah I think
with with the search a safe King and him
having so many pawn weaknesses I think
in in practical terms I'm still I'm
still fine but yeah I did feel as he as
though he was a little better but I'm
but I think in in practical terms it's
it's it's very hard and I wouldn't it
wouldn't surprise me also if a fan gene
some major deaths just said it's it's
more or less equal because white coming
too much yeah one thing we were
wondering during the live show was
Ruki eight it seems like you've created
a thread but maybe it's just possible to
ignore it in place for it yeah I was
that was the thing I was the most
worried about I was gonna probably gonna
play you fire but I didn't like it
because then you have to play that
endgame which maybe you hold but it's
not it shouldn't be much fun right after
85 and yeah we need stakes we can how
you drew the rookie i but i don't think
it matters
i think it's the same position yeah yeah
and king age 7 and probably rooted for
exactly here would I wasn't there sure
actually g5 I guess he goes age 5 most
of the time still and then maybe rook c5
and maybe you Roxy fire so it feels like
it's we then but still there there's c4
than 93 is the threat I mean I did this
was the one point where I didn't really
didn't really like my position very much
but probably there is some some more
accurate way to play but I didn't I
didn't particularly find it and then
once uh once you got the route d8 move
in and feels every time out of danger he
tries to win and with
starch disparity and paste activity in
king safety trying to win this is almost
always going to be equivalent to a loss
but I I I guess after Magnus we have a
question a question from our social
media for you honor will bridge the gap
honor thank you yes sir we need have
many questions for Magnus but I have
selected one which is a double question
from China mark Magnus how do you feel
about rapid chess versus classical chess
and do you see kids becoming an eSport
if you could answer those questions
separately yeah sure
well these days I'm playing a lot of
rapid chess I don't know I've sort of
always found to repeat just the most
difficult because it's because it's such
a tricky hybrid between classical and
blitz chess and there almost though
there's almost always going to be two
phases of the game one classical face
and and one blitz face and and to
balance them it's very very hard but I
think it's also a very entertaining form
form of clay and even though I find a
difficult time I still I still enjoy it
both as as a spectator but also as as a
player and in terms of just becoming a
nice porch
I think never never fully like or
exclusively any sport but I think it's
part of the direction where chess is
going that more more the activity is
going to be the beamline
and I don't mind it to be fair thank you
for your insight and answers the rest of
the questions are all related to and if
you
I don't know if you want to comment on
that but Elvin is here with us aravinda
me the second of a nice giri has joined
us for this round any thoughts on the
recent witty banter Magnus I think the
tweets speak for themselves both both
ways but having said that I wish I wish
good luck and I reiterate my wish to see
him in the finals the ball is on a
Nicias side I really have one is here to
represent unaged interest in any
contractual matters or when do you do
you agree that Amish would be satisfied
to reach the finals I think that this I
think we can settle that right right
right here right now
Thank You Freddy all right that's very
very nice other questions honor for
Magnus as he made a very convincing
statement that he is a semi finalist I
think also the questions are involving a
niche and the comment from mr. Dodge it
was a guess simply whether Magnus's
varying long pants or shorts so this is
about the level of the conversation
right now
got it we won't go there will be we can
give that the sacred Magnus we have
another semi-finalists
neppo he also won and very convincing
style against the winner of the
preliminary group does that result
surprised you and just a comment on
Nepos play well technically I won the
preliminary replies okay no I obviously
our Tamiya fish is strong but I always
believed that John could do well there
and I'm happy for him yeah
is struggled quite a bit in this online
events and know whoever he he faces in
the in the semis he will he will not be
an underdog so he has a very good chance
wonderful thank you fishing we should be
one Magnus no I haven't what you you
will you will have a moment of pure joy
than when you when you get I can I guess
I can bring it up on on this on this
board actually in this position in this
position
young played this for five be one if you
can see it on your screen which is oh
yeah that is a nice move yeah that is
nice that is a nice move to to look at
but I think if you would if you would
pick one player in the field to actually
find this move it would be on so yeah
yeah I think I think we can trust on him
on that but still it's a when I saw that
I got I got briefly very excited well if
you follow what Peter you go this should
be one for a moment the one that I
really liked was Bishop e2 the answer to
Bishop e2 but yeah baby Queen yeah and
rook e1 checkmate that's that's that's
extra special the the whole Bishop d1
concept very impressive look look great
thrilled us Magnus well okay guys
another short day for us at the office
Magnus I want to thank you very much for
joining us that was very gracious of you
Erwin fantastic with your chess course
again you get a big discount by
purchasing our wins chest wall course
and any final thoughts that you'd like
to share Peter not not what I expected
to see today to be to to be entirely
honest I thought that you know one set
in particularly in the in the Magnus
match ending in three games was already
unusual but but to where
would have been a long shot but yeah
very very convincing play well by the
world champion both days and Yuans
victory today I think was in very
different to today one where I think
events slightly conspired in his favor
today he was just a better player and
[Music]
very a very deserving winner as well and
tomorrow of course we'll have to
Armageddon's because we never get two of
these days in a row
exactly get the flipside tomorrow we'll
be back for matches C and D tomorrow's
or in but before we leave we have
another learning moment that we would
like to share with you Anna
take it away please I believe it's going
to be the honor of our guest our author
of the day Airin Lumiere mean I will
need to put you on the spot and ask you
which moment was your favorite of the
day what would you choose as learning
moment of today's round all of the games
included okay I thought Game one between
Fabiano and and Marcus that was that was
one interesting home in general I think
that with Fabi playing this Bishop d2 an
interplay for small advantage then he
actually got a bird rotate we go to move
14 I believe it was after Knight takes
e5 DC Knight takes e5 I thought it
wasn't interesting a moment I displeased
in which we have on the board now
because of the Queen c2 black played
Queen 86 and bishops III followed Knight
fe4 and to me it was quite remarkable
how quickly white from a seemingly safe
position actually got into a very bad
position I don't know if it was lost at
any point but it was very much on the
edge I think at some point and instead
of going to see two or more 15 I think
an interesting way to play here would be
Queen to be 5 so you prevent the Queen
from from going to a6 and in black now
plays a move like net Fe for let's let's
say you just go night 84 and next up is
rook c2 rook F c1 quincannon veto
back to e2 Previn bishop a1 is also
moved and this is I think the type of
game that
Fabiano was actually aiming for here we
can play for some small advantage and
and and see whatever comes up and yeah I
thought it was interesting to see those
small differences going back to c2
actually landed him in a bit of trouble
and I think if it couldn't be 5 he would
still be actually hoping to get the type
of game that he was he was aiming for it
was not a huge moment perhaps but I
thought interesting to see how these
small details they actually change the
entire course of the game because if the
Queen c2 yeah it was just a long way of
suffering for for white basically yeah
and also I wanted to add to that that in
in a more general sense in these
isolated positions you want to restrict
the black counterplay as much as
possible and black does need to serve
there are two modes of games you get in
structures like this the kind of a game
Magnus got where he got a lot of free
piece play using the rooks on EA tanned
see it if you just look at this position
every single piece black has and on a
perfect square there is 93 ideas Knight
a four ideas the Queen on a success as
Aaron was describing very active the
rooks are on perfect open and semi open
files or if that doesn't materialize and
white controls this type of counter play
black often has to defend for like 50
moves with zero counter play and really
zero the zero joy out of life and often
it is those very very little sim
seemingly very little decisions that
that make make the difference and I
think Bobby played Queen c2 more or less
instantaneously as well so well perhaps
it's a rare rare case of an extremely
strong player missing a pivotal moment
where he should have spent some time
figuring out what his options are and
what the pros and cons are actually in
the in the second game if I if I may I
had one more question there in the
technical phase at the moment he went
III for Magnus
I mean I'm a big fan of exchange
sacrifices myself and I was extremely
drawn to rook gg7 here and after King f8
or Bishop d4 actually I think it goes
shade
- maybe it's not so simple you can start
with Luke a7 here which is probably also
a very clean way of finishing sick
fishing I think so because you catch a
disease threat mm-hmm and you probably
think oh yeah now I go B shoot afore and
h5 is hanging and you know it's just
completely yeah that is nice
I'm not sure I'm not sure I can say this
is better than what Marcus did because I
think man I mean II for was fine but I
it's just made of taste perhaps and I
like to give exchanges so that's why I
thought this yeah that's that that's a
nice nice idea I think I missed rook h7
when we were looking at this and also we
appreciated yeah we were very fixated on
the idea of playing e4 because it does
appear to be close to completely winning
yeah we did later on it did look like he
was still fighting or or well maybe I
maybe I'm wrong Ashley but that was the
rook takes f6 rook at six
yeah you didn't get into a single rook
ending but it really felt like Bobby was
not only material now but really on the
back foot I want to just get you in here
as we're getting ready to close the show
to inform people about what is happening
in banter chess Anna very important
question indeed yes sir since we do have
every single evening a banter with show
for you by the chasuble masters and
today it is the one and only
Fabiana Khurana he may have lost his
match today and he may well be not with
us unfortunately from tomorrow on Magnus
Carson moves on to the semifinals
Fabiano will not be playing against the
rest of the chess webmasters but he will
be playing against chess 24 premium
members tonight at 8 p.m. Central
European Time so take your chance to
challenge the world number 2 for a game
on chess 24 and as you can see that
calendar features some really high
profile names tomorrow it will be Magnus
Carson's turn to take challenges on
chests 24 thank you for that and as we
close the show I'd again like to think
Grand Master Erwin Lonnie for joining us
pointing out those two very nice pivotal
moments is actually like the first
learning moment or when you can get
Berlin's course at a 46 percent discount
order today and or when thank you so
much for joining us I think it was a
very great pleasure to be here the best
representative of a nice no question
about that final thoughts Peter as we
close the show I'm all out of final
thoughts I'm very excited for tomorrow I
am somewhat grateful for for the shorter
days but it doesn't feel quite right
without the Blitz and the Armageddon and
[Music]
so farther that those days clearly
alternated so I'm expecting some of that
tomorrow wonderful thank you for that
everybody thank you for joining us thank
you for being a part of our broadcasts
for supporting our streams were being
here tell your friends where you're
hanging out and become a Premium Member
a Premium Member get involved in the
banner blitz and support wonderful
authors like erling or me thank you all
for joining us and we'll see you
tomorrow for the next day of
quarterfinals matches good night
everyone
there are more moves in chess than atoms
in the universe
only one move ends again
[Music]
[Music]
my name is John Bartholomew and this is
the checkmate patterns manual
you